Laurent Castignette, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Serview. On
vous reçoit dans le domaine de votre
activité sur l'étude de la pollution et
toutes ces petites choses autour de
l'automobile
et de la consommation énergétique
peut-être. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Al, j'ai 48
ans, je suis ingénieur, je suis passé
par l'école centrale. Ensuite, j'ai
travaillé dans le bâtiment dans la
conception automobile et depuis 10 ans,
j'ai un bureau d'étude en environnement
qui s'appelle BCO deingénierie à
Bordeaux. Et il y a 4 ans, je me suis
lancé dans l'écriture d'un livre qui est
sorti l'année dernière qui s'appelle euh
Airvor ou la face obscure des transports
aux éditions écociété.
Ça consiste en quoi Airvor ? Ça parle de
quoi la Airvor ou la face obscure des
transports ? Oui. Alors, Airvor, déjà,
c'est un mot inventé qui euh qui
s'inspire un petit peu de de l'époque
des d'idosaures finalement euh qui
étaient à la fois carnivore, herbivore.
Et aujourd'hui, les transports motorisés
sont devenus tellement hégémoniques
qu'on peut ils ils ont rempli nos vies,
ils les remplissent de plus en plus, un
petit peu comme à l'époque des
dinosaures où finalement toutes les
autres espèces animales devaient se
ranger derrière ces espèces qui
remplissaient la terre. Et ensuite, le
sous-titre, c'est chronique d'une
pollution annoncée qui rappelle un petit
peu l'ouvrage de Garcia Marquez. où
finalement on a l'impression que à la
fois la dérive du climat ainsi que la
pollution des grands centres urbains est
est inéluctable malgré beaucoup de
discours, malgré des actions, mais
finalement on a l'impression que tout
converge vers le fait que cette
pollution ne sera pas du tout résorbée
au contraire et que le climat va être
dérégulé.
Mais pourquoi vous dites ça ? Il y a
Anil Dalgot qui fait plein de travaux à
Paris. Il y a plein de de de sociétés,
d'hommes de bonne volonté qui essayent
de de faire des voitures moins
polluantes, des diesels sans trop de
particules, des des politiques qui qui
font des des des sommets à l'autre bout
du monde en jet privé, des taxis qui
attendent nos ministres, des voitures de
fonction qui attendent nos ministres
avec la climatisation qui tourne plein
pot pour faire 800 m h
il y a des gens qui se battent pour le
climat non ? Oui, enfin ils se battent.
Alors effectivement la manière dont ils
se battent effectivement peut être
criticable quand vous voyez
[raclement de gorge] effectivement la
Noria d'avion. Et puis dernièrement par
exemple, on a vu Greta Tunberg qui se
qui voulait absolument prendre le train
pour aller à la dernière COPE en venant
de Suède pour aller en Pologne. Et oui,
ça fait beaucoup d'émissions tout ça.
Ensuite la le deuxième sujet, c'est
finalement est-ce que nos grands
dirigeants s'occupent vraiment des
véritables sources ? C'est ça aussi. ils
font des choses sur des des des parties,
on va parler des transports, ils
prennent des des initiatives, mais
finalement globalement les émissions
continuent d'augmenter. Donc la question
c'est est-ce que leurs initiatives
est-ce qu'elles ne sont pas efficaces
parce que finalement ils ne font rien ou
alors finalement sont pas est-ce
qu'elles ne sont pas efficace parce
qu'ils ne s'attaquent pas véritablement
au vrai sujet ou alors ils partent d'un
mauvais diagnostic
ou il s'y attaquent pas parce que sinon
ça nique l'économie, ça fout l'économie
en récession, ça met plein de chômeurs
qui se transforment en gros gilet jaunes
bien énervés et c'est peut-être pour ça
que bon il traite le le truc avec un peu
un peu de ripolin de temps en temps.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, effectivement,
ils sont ils sont un petit peu coincés
aujourd'hui dans la recherche permanente
d'une croissance économique euh qui pour
eux qui pour eux est le salut euh et le
salut finalement du chômage mais qui se
traduit finalement cette croissance- là
par une augmentation des pollutions. On
peut rentrer dans le détail, je sais pas
sur quel domaine vous voulez qu'on
l'aborde, mais si on par vous venez de
parler des gilets jaunes. Bon, les
gilets jaunes, le déclenchement des
gilets jaunes, c'était finalement les
transports qui l'ont déclenché,
notamment l'augmentation du prix des
carburants. Alors, les gilets jaunes,
ils sont très disparates évidemment,
mais l'analyse transport des gilets
jaunes qu'on pourrait faire, c'est de
constater que ces gens-là finalement,
ils se sont installé, ils sont installés
assez loin en général des des bassins
emploi, de leur travail finalement avec
une équation économique qu'ils ont faite
qui est de se dire en m'éloignant
finalement des lieux d'emploi, je vais
pouvoir avoir souvent plus de mètres
carrés de logement parce que finalement
les mètres carrés sont très chers
proches des bassins d'emploi et
finalement une voiture, ce n'est pas si
cher en plus si elle les diesel et donc
finalement ils ont ils ont ils se sont
installés personnellement en fonction
d'une équation économique qu'ils ont vu
se dégrader à la fois économiquement
puisque le prix du carburant augmentait
et aussi en terme de temps de transport.
Euh ce que je voudrais souligner c'est
qu'en fait la la distance domicile
travail par exemple des gens et ça c'est
vrai depuis plus de 100 ans, il y a deux
il y a deux critères majeurs qui sont le
temps de transport et le coût de ce et
le coût marginal de ce transport. Voilà.
Et ces gens-là finalement constatent que
ben leur temps de déplacement augmente
souvent. Moi, j'arrive de Bordeaux, la
rocade est de plus en plus encombré et
donc les gens qui avaient tablés sur
peut-être tris qu4 d'heure, une heure
pour aller travailler petit à petit se
rendent compte que ce temps augmente et
puis que les prix augmentent et leur
équation finalement patatra, elle n'est
plus vraiment valable. Alors, qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? En fait, il faudrait qu'on
analyse ça. Eux, eux demandent en fait
que les carburants soient considérés
comme une pomme de terre, c'est-à-dire
qu'il soit détaxé parce que pour eux,
c'est vital, c'est un produit de
première nécessité. Donc, il réclament
que il n'y ait plus du tout de taxe et
que finalement leur transport soit
encore moins cher.
C'est taxé à combien L de gasoil ?
Alors, le litre de gasoil aujourd'hui
proportionnellement, il a à peu près
vendu le double de son prix hors taxe,
grosso modo, ce qui peut paraître
beaucoup, mais en fait qui est faible au
regard de l'histoire. C'est-à-dire que
le carburant était très taxé au début du
bien plus que ça au début du 20e siècle.
Euh les taxes représentaient 80 %
jusqu'aux années 50 du prix du carburant
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est que 50. Euh
et les associations automobilistes se
plaignaient déjà dans les années 30 du
fait que ils étaient beaucoup trop
taxés. Donc, il y a des études qui ont
été faites par euh missionnées par
l'État, l'équivalent de la Cour des
comptes d'aujourd'hui dans les années 30
et qui a montré que malgré toutes les
taxes qui taxes qui étaient beaucoup
plus nombreuses qu'aujourd'hui sur le
carburant, on s'est rendu compte que
finalement l'État, les collectivités
locales dépensaient beaucoup plus dans
les infrastructures finalement que
l'argent qu'il récoltait des taxes sur
les voitures et sur l'essence. Donc déjà
à l'époque, il y avait déjà un écart.
Dans les années 60, ce débat euh c'est a
repris euh justement pour reconstater
qu'il y avait toujours finalement que
les la la voiture était sponsorisée
finalement par les doners publics malgré
des taxes qui étaient comme je vous dis
encore très fortes et aujourd'hui la
situation est bien pire. C'est malgré
ces taxes importantes, on regarde que
l'État continue à financer l'essentiel
des infrastructures nouvelles, leur
entretien. La pollution de l'air des
transports, les gens malades par la
sécurité sociale, ce sont ce sont pas
les l'automobiles qui les pai
directement. Et puis enfin, il y a le
changement climatique avec euh les le
début des infrastructures qu'il va
falloir construire qui vont être prises
en charge par les États. Il y a aussi
une partie des conséquences des
accidents. Donc finalement, si on fait
le bilan de tout ça, on va se rendre
compte que finalement l'automobile et
les transports en général continuent
d'être sponsorisé par les denniers
publics et et les gilets jaunes dans
tout ça finalement ils se sont installés
dans donc si on reprend ce qui s'est
passé, les analyses qui sont faites
depuis 100 ans, il faudrait reprendre
par exemple ce que disait Wells, donc
Herbert George Wells, qui est le on va
dire le Jul Verne anglais qui a écrit la
guerre des mondes, il a fait un auteur
de science-fiction mais qui a surtout
écrit un livre d'anticipation qu'il a
appelé anticipation et à l'époque il
faisait une analyse très pertinente qui
s'est révélé exact en tout cas depuis
plusieurs siècles qui est le fait que
les grandes villes du monondre leur
diamètre était lié aux moyens de
transport utilisé par les masses. Il
constatait que depuis des siècles les
grandes villes avaient à peu près 6 km
de rayon dans le monde et au-delà elle
ne grandissait plus parce que c'était la
marche le moyen de transport massif. Les
grandes villes qui commençaient à
s'équiper de chevaux en grand nombre
pouvaient croître un petit peu en taille
jusqu'à une dizaine de kilomètres. Et
lui en 1900, il se projette en l'an 2000
et il dit alors à l'époque il voit
l'automobile moderne qui qui émerge
depuis les années 90 1890.
Il se placeent en 1900, il se projette
en l'an 2000 et il se dit "An mon avis
en l'an 2000 les moyens de transport
motorisés à disposition des masses
auront 50 km/h de moyenne. Ce qui est
une prédiction extraordinaire et il dit
donc les grandes villes du monde auront
50 km de diamètre." Et aujourd'hui,
c'est ce qu'on constate par exemple la
région parisienne où on voit que les
gens sont capables de faire 30 40 km
pour aller travailler. Et donc cette
prédiction là, elle s'est révélée,
elle a commencé à être effective dans
les années 50. En fait, dans les années
20 déjà, Henry Ford qui lui donc c'était
le pape de l'industrie Henry Ford dans
les années 20. Il faut voir qu'en en
1920, vous avez Ford qui a 3/4 du marché
mondial de l'automobile. Il y a une
voiture sur deux dans le monde qui est
une Fordet T. Et donc il est écouté par
toute l'industrie et dans ses pas ses
mémoires puisqu'il a écrit de son enfin
il était encore actif. Il écrit que lui
il voit poindre un nouveau marché dans
les années 20 qui est le trajet
d'homicile travail en voiture en
[raclement de gorge] voiture. Alors que
jusque- là finalement les gens pour
aller au travail s'il se déplaçait pas à
pied ou en vélo, c'était dans des bus ou
des ou des camions. Et dans les années
50 Lesisford lui commence à constater
que finalement la mise à disposition de
transport rapide dans l'Amérique des
années 50 mais finalement conduit à
rallonger les distances notamment
d'homicile travail et [grognement] nous
on a vu ça avec 20 ans de retard
finalement en Europe. Bernard
Charbonauotu le re le reindique dans les
années 60.
Ivanilic ensuite dans les années 70 et
pour vous donner juste un chiffre, un le
le trajet domicile travail d'un français
au début des années 60 c'était 3 km. À
la fin des années 60, c'était déjà 6 et
vers 2010 c'était 15. Donc en fait, on a
mis à disposition des gens aux gens de
voiture rapides en leur disant enfin en
leur faisant croire qu'ils allaient
gagner du temps. Alors que la réalité
c'est qu'on a largement augmenté les
distance et finalement le temps
d'omicile travail, il n'a fait
finalement qu'augmenter. Ce qui est un
énorme paradoxe. Maintenant, on voit des
gens qui travaillent à Paris mais qui
habitent à Renn.
Oui. Oui. Ou qui habitent à Bordeaux.
Ouais. [rires] Ou à
Tout à fait. et qui finalement alors
certains ne vont faire le trajet que une
à deux fois par semaine, mais au total
en heure de transport, on se retrouve
finalement avec une certaine stabilité
et euh ben Charbonau par exemple disait
que si un jour on se retrouvait avec
Bordeaux, le centre de Bordeaux à à 1h
des bureaux de l'opéra, et bien en gros
la France serait une vaste banlieue
c'està-dire finalement plus on facilite
en masse la mise en place de transport
rapide, finalement les gens ils
arbitrent sur le temps des transports
rapides et bon marché.
les gens arbitrent sur le tron de
transport. Donc finalement le nombre
d'heures passé dans les transports est
stable, voire en augmentation. Et ben
comme disait Charbonau, finalement le le
salarié moyen, on il est obligé de se
créer un deuxième emploi qui est
l'emploi de chauffeur de lui-même.
Donc maintenant, on voit des voitures
électriques qui roulent au nucléaires,
qui roulent au charbon,
qui
décentre la la production de de
pollution. C'estàd qu'on on se retrouve
plus avec des gaz d'échappement mais on
se retrouve avec des mines d'uranium
où on se retrouve avec tout un un tas de
florilège de pollution.
Il y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur la
voiture équip dans ce que vous avez dit.
Alors déjà la question c'est comment est
l'électricité ? Elle est-ce qu'elle est
nucléaire ? Est-ce qu'elle est
autocharbon ? Il y a plusieurs choses à
dire sur la voiture électrique. Il y a
déjà trois grands sujets qui sont
[raclement de gorge] déjà les métaux
disponibles à l'extraction sur la
planète sous 30 ans. On n' pas la
possibilité de substituer la totalité du
parc routier. Voilà. Aujourd'hui, on a
un milliard,
c'est pas ce que dit Laurent Alexandre,
hein.
Voilà. Alors, enfin, après, on pourra
débattre du de ce qui est du de ce qui
relève du messianisme technologique, de
l'extractivisme à gogo, de la planète
Infinie. En tout cas, dans le cas de la
voiture électrique, voilà, dans le cas
de la voiture électrique, il y a on a
déjà un problème de ressources
métalliques. Métallique en général,
c'est bien pas qu'un seul métal qui est
concerné. Vous avez le lithium, le
cobalt, le platine, même le cuivre dans
ses réserves les les plus concentrées
ainsi que d'autres métaux parce que
quand on arrive à à faire une nouvelle
technologie qui euh qui s'affranchit
plus ou moins d'un métal, c'est c'est en
utilisant un autre qui fait partie un
peu de la même catégorie de ces métaux
en tension qui sont d'ailleurs pour
certains beaucoup plus en tension que le
pétrole. Donc il y a il y a des il y a
il y a un avenir de géopolitique sur le
le cobal qui interroge he où la moitié
des réserves mondiales sont dans un seul
pays. Le platine c'est 2 tiers la moitié
entre la moitié de 2 tiers en Afrique du
Sud. Le Cobalt c'est dans la République
du Congo dans une des régions du Congo
simplement.
Je leur prédis on va dire de la
démocratie bientôt chez eux.
Voilà. Et sachant que vous avez les
constructeurs aujourd'hui qui qui
dialoguent directement avec les les
mines du Congo pour pouvoir obtenir des
garanti de volume, ce qui est quand même
un court circuitage de la totalité des
fournisseurs. Bon voilà, donc vous avez
un problème de tension sur les métaux
qui fait qu' on peut pas imaginer qu'on
aura si vous voulez dans 30 ans tout le
monde en voiture électrique. Quand je
dis tout le monde voiture électrique,
les camions aussi. Voilà, on peut pas
substituer la totalité. Ce n'est pas
physiquement possible à un horizon de
quelques décennies. Ça c'est le premier
sujet.
Un peu moins, ça va. Ah oui ! Alors si
vous avez une extermination massive, on
pourra en parler. Enfin, on pourra
peut-être pas en reparler parce qu'on
fera peut-être on sera peut-être
concerné. Euh ensuite le
plus vous que moi.
Alors de deuxième sujet, c'est la
fabrication des batteries elle-même qui
est très émissive, ce qui fait que du
coup ça pose question sur les véhicules
qui vont être peu utilisés. Finalement,
un véhicule qui va faire peu de
kilomètres globalement, valait-il pas
mieux qu'il soit en en moteur thermique
si on a fini par jamais grosso modo
amortir le supplément de fabrication de
la batterie qui peut représenter plus de
la moitié de de la voiture équivalente
donc en à kilomè 0 au démarrage.
L'impact de la batterie, 3è sujet, vous
l'avez cité, c'est quid de la
fabrication d'électricité. Alors, je
parle d'électricité supplémentaire et le
gros souci qu'on a aujourd'hui, que ce
soit en Europe, dans le monde, en Chine,
c'est que on a beau mettre en place
plein de euh nouvel système de
production d'énergie renouvelable, on
n'arrive même pas à satisfaire
l'augmentation de demande. C'estd malgré
ça, la Chine qui est le plus gros
installateur d'énergie renouvelable
éolien et cetera, il continue à mettre
en route des centrales en énergie
fossile. Ça veut dire que si demain on
substitue une partie du parc routier en
électrique, parc routier qui aujourd'hui
ne croise pas le réseau électrique et
mais finalement on va augmenter une
demande qui n'arrive pas être à être
satisfaite. Donc du coup on aura la
plupart des pays où ça va être
finalement de l'énergie fossile qui va
le fabriquer. En France, c'est pas du
tout évident qu'elle soit si nucléaire
que ça parce que vous avez beaucoup de
périodes de l'année où les centrales
nucléaires allumées sont à fond ou alors
elles sont arrêtées. Donc si on augmente
la demande aujourd'hui, on n'est pas en
train de construire un réacteur
nucléaire justifié, éventuellement
financé par action par les gens qui vont
acheter une voiture électrique. Pas du
tout.
Ou une trottinette électrique. Pas du
tout. Aujourd'hui, ils s'équipent de de
matériel électrique sans se poser la
question de mettre en place un moy
eux-mêmes un moyen supplémentaire.
Donc voilà. Donc ça c'est les trois
sujets, on va dire techniques. Et après
vous avez un sujet psychologique sur la
voiture électrique qui est le fait de se
dire "Ben le messianisme technologique à
quoi il aboutit au fait de se dire mais
finalement on a une voiture thermique,
on va acheter une voiture toujours plus
grosse électrique et le problème sera
résolu. Alors qu'en fait la question
c'est profiter de l'électrique. Quand je
dis profiter, je vais vous expliquer,
pour réinterroger la puissance, la masse
de nos véhicules actuels. profiter à la
faveur du fait qu'aujourd'hui les
véhicules électriques, leur batterie
n'étant pas du tout aussi puissante
enfin capacitaire que peuvent l'être un
réservoir de carburant liquide à ce
moment-là ben à cause de autonomie
limitée, on est obligé de baisser la
puissance, d'avoir un véhicule pas très
performant. Donc c'est l'occasion
pendant quelques années de se
réinterroger sur le le gabarit, la
puissance des voitures.
Pas très performant en terme de quoi ?
Pas très performant en terme de kilwh
embarqué par litre ou par kilogram de
batterie. C'est pour ça que les voitures
aujourd'hui n'ont que quelques pas
beaucoup centaines de kilomètres et
qu'elles sont en écart par rapport à
l'autonomie des des véhicules
thermiques. Mais c'est l'occasion de se
dire "Mais finalement, est-ce qu'on a
vraiment de besoin de voitures aussi
lourdes et aussi puissantes finalement
pour prouver son taux de testostérone ?"
Non. Voilà. Alors,
vous êtes ingénieur vous ? Non, vous
êtes pas vous travaillez pas du tout
dans la com
vous avez toujours pas compris qu'on
vendait des voitures pour
Ah mais bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais on on
vend des Il faut voir les publicités
aussi. Les publicités, il faut les voir.
Il y a deux sujets. Il y a ce que vous
dites qui est le flatter l'ego du
propriétaire. Et il y a un deuxième
sujet sur la publicité automobile
aujourd'hui qui est assez surprenant,
c'est de voir qu'elles sont tout le
temps filmé dans un désert automobile.
C'est-à-dire, c'est tout le temps des
des des gens souriants qui naviguent
dans des contrées spacieuses, dans des
villes vides et qui du coup euh donc il
y a un certain mensonge qui est fait
aussi aux gilets jaunes, c'estàdire de
leur vendre finalement une voiture qui
leur permettra une énorme liberté et
puis après avec la même voiture, ils se
retrouvent coincés dans les
embouteilles. Les gilets jaunes, ils
roulent pas en voiture électrique ? Non.
Il roulent en vieille voiture, on est en
train de les ghettoiser des des villes
en leur disant voilà qui a plus de 10
ans,
les transports motorisés pas chers ont
permis justement d'éloigner des villes
les salaires pas chers vu de l'employeur
en fait.
Éloigner des villes
les villes du cœur des villes du cœur
des emplois salaires pas chers. C'est ce
que vous avez dit.
Voilà, c'est exactement. C'estàdire
on peut les qualifier d'esclave.
Est-ce qu'on peut en fait d'esclaves
d'esclaves énergétiqu ? Oui. Alors, en
fait, notion d'esclave énergétiste
énergétique, on peut parler d'énergie
esclavagiste aussi, c'est-à-dire le fait
que euh l'énergie pas chère euh il il
faut se mettre à la place d'un employeur
avec des transports massifs pas chers
individuels, la zone de chalandis, la
zone de chalandise en employé d'un
employeur est extrêmement vaste. C'est
assez extraordinaire, ce qui n'était pas
du tout le cas il y a il y a une
centaine d'années ou un peu moins.
C'est-à-dire que à l'époque, une grosse
usine, enfin je une unité industrielle
qui avait besoin de beaucoup de main
d'œuvre, bon ben elle allait prendre
celle du village qui était autour ou qui
habitait plus ou moins sur place et si
elle en voulait davantage, il fallait
qu'elle paye qu'elle organise elle-même
des des transports, des camions qui
allaient chercher les gens dans les
villages à quelques kilomètres ou un
petit peu plus. Donc finalement le
transport domicile travail était
entièrement organisé et pris en charge
par l'employeur. On est passé en 100 ans
à complètement l'inverse. C'estàd que en
gros le transport d'istravail est
quasiment aujourd'hui de la
responsabilité de l'employé.
Alors avant quand on était esclave
c'était votre
employeur esclavagiste qui vous payait
le git, le couvert et le transport
et maintenant ça a changé.
Après il faut
maintenant il faut qu'on se paye notre
git, il faut qu'on se paye notre
transport. Après, on on parle du
domicistravail, mais il y a un autre
sujet euh en terme de d'esclavage
moderne, c'est les le transport des
marchandises. C'estàd qu'aujourd'hui le
fait finalement euh d'avoir transformé,
d'avoir métamorphosé un petit peu le
citoyen en consommateur. Ce que je dire
par là, c'est que il y a quelques
décennies, le citoyen qui a qui qui euh
acquiérait des biens ou qui s'achetait
des produits alimentaires, il venait de
pas très loin ces produits-là. Donc
s'ils étaient fabriqués dans avec par
des esclaves, en gros c'était une
quelques dizaines de kilomètres ou si
jamais l'usine elle pollueit massivement
son environnement, ça se savait en gros.
Voilà. Donc les gens auraient pu en
avoir honte ou alors ça se faisait pas
trop. Aujourd'hui, finalement, les
transports motorisés euh se sont
tellement développés à l'échelle du
globe se ont largement baissé en prix
alors à la faveur de leur organisation,
à la faveur d'un carburant pas cher, à
la faveur des accords de libre échange
qui sont développés qui fait que
finalement on a une cascade de
fournisseur aujourd'hui avec le paravant
d'une marque et d'une belle publicité
qui fait que finalement le citoyen
aujourd'hui n'a plus du tout conscience
finalement de de du lieu de fabrication
et donc des conditions dans laquelles
les ouvriers, on va dire, l'ont euh
l'ont fabriqué. Et en plus dans le cas
des produits polluants, on a même
tendance des fois à ne pas vouloir les
recycler, à les exporter dans d'autres
pays du même type. Donc finalement, le
citoyen métamorphosé en consommateur par
les transports motorisés, c'est c'est ça
ça relève aussi de ce de cette dérive en
fait.
On va parler un peu du diesel gate.
On verra après sur ce sujet un peu un
peu un peu plus tard. Le diesel gate,
c'est quoi ?
Vous me donnez une minute ou un quart
d'heure,
une petite demi-heure si vous voulez.
Bon, ce que je vous propose c'est
d'essayer de comprendre enfin l'essence
du dieselgate, désolé.
[raclement de gorge]
L'origine. L'origine, il y a une part,
on va dire psychologique, il y a une
part technique, je dirais une part
manageriale. La partie psychologique,
c'est qu'il faut comprendre quelle est
la pression à certains moments de
certains constructeurs.
Pour résumer, le dieselgate, c'est une
bonne grosse truanderie à l'ancienne
pour gruger les normes antipollution.
Oui. Alors, quand vous dites à
l'ancienne, euh vous avez bien raison,
je sais pas si vous imaginez à
l'ancienne pour vous de quel de quelle
ancien ancienneté vous parlez. En fait,
lorsqu'on revient à l'origine de
l'automobile, donc l'automobile moderne,
hein, je parle pas des voitures sans
chevaux anglaises des années 1830, mais
l'automobile moderne des années 90, bon
1895 qui est arrivé en France, pas en
Angleterre parce que final, alors que
pourtant ça aurait l'automobile aurait
dû éclore en Angleterre ce qu'elle a
fait avec la machine à vapeur dans les
années 30, mais il y a eu plein de les
lobby des diligences, des chemins de fer
ont tout fait pour tuer le marché et
donc c'est pour ça que finalement
l'automobile moner n'est pas né en
Angleterre mais en France dans les
années 90 essentiellement de 1895 à 1900
105, c'était le les constructeurs
français qui étaient les les plus gros
producteurs du monde, le parc automobile
français qui était en tête. Bon et euh
vers 19 à partir de 1903, il y a eu donc
les les construeurs ne pouvaient pas
faire de publicité, ils étaient trop
petits à l'époque. Et donc la publicité
passait par les compétitions. Les
compétitions étaient organisées. C'était
compétitions de vitesse jusqu'à à peu
près exclusivement jusqu'à 1903 sur
route ouverte. Bon, il y a eu des
compétitions avec beaucoup de morts à un
moment qui fait qu'on les a fait sur
circuit et vers 1905 par là, vous aviez
deux types de compétitions à l'époque
sur circuit. Certaines mettaient en
valeur le premier qui gagnait donc il
avait en gros la voiture la plus rapide,
ça passait dans les journaux, ça lui
faisait une bonne publicité. Il y avait
énormément de constructeurs à l'époque
he une centaine en France hein. Bon
grosse concurrence. Et il y avait aussi
des consommations de des compétitions de
consommation, c'est-à-dire le nombre de
tours n'était pas fixé du même circuit
et celui qui gagnait, c'est celui qui
avait consommé le moins par rapport au
nombre de tours qu'il avait parcouru.
Donc c'était calculé en litre au 100. Et
donc gagner un gagner un concours de
consommation à l'époque c'est ça avait
autant d'impact que de gagner une course
de vitesse sur le même circuit. Et donc
ça sous-entendait que la voiture ben
elle était économe et comme l'essence
était très cher comme je vous ai dit
hein, produits de luxe denré colonial
euh ben c'était l'occasion de booster
les ventes. Bon et ben à l'époque vous
aviez de la triche qui était paru dans
la presse sur le fait que les
constructeurs, les mécanaux des
constructeurs se vantaient un peu les
uns les autres pour dire moi, je suis
capable de mettre dedans mettre dedans
les les commissaires de course qui eux
plombaient les réservoirs pour être sûr.
Donc il mesuraient le carburant qui
avait dedans. Il plombait les réservoirs
et à la fin de la course il remettaiit
de l'essence et en fonction de ceil
remettait, il recalculait. Il du coup
ils estimaient l'occan et il y avait une
concurrence sur les constructeurs qui
bon qui c'était un peu du bluff et de la
réalité qui disait moi je suis capable
de contourner tout ça et pas toi. Et
donc il y avait certaines courses
consommation gagnées qui du coup étaient
hyper suspectes et donc beaucoup
d'articles dans la presse sur le sujet
et même on est allé jusqu'à avoir des
grosses voitures qui consommaient 1 L au
100. Donc évidemment exclu exclu des
résultats. On se doutait du norme
triche. qui a même eu à l'époque une
voiture qui a même produit du carburant,
ce qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire. C'estàd qu'elle elle a
fini la course avec plus de carburant
qu'elle avait commencé. Donc évidemment
la superurée a été découverte par un
remplissage. Donc voilà, vous voyez à
l'époque il y avait même dans la presse
des concours ouverts aux lecteurs pour
proposer des triches sur la
réglementation pour démontrer que cette
réglementation était finalement
inadaptée, qu'elle était facilement
contournable. Donc ce sujet était
vraiment très vif dans les années zéro
enfin 1900 1910. Bon donc les
constructeurs, beaucoup de pression pour
et puis un peu à la limite de la
tricherie. Bon ça c'est le premier
sujet. Ensuite le diesel get. Alors le
diesel get il y a le mot diesel. Pour
comprendre le diesel get il faut
comprendre quelle a été la pression sur
les constructeurs européens qui ont
voulu se lancer le diesel aux
États-Unis. Alors pourquoi le diesel a
été lancé aux États-Unis dans les années
2000 en voiture ? Il faut comprendre ça.
Dans les années 60, vous avez des pays
d'Europe de l'Ouest, 60 70 d'Europe de
l'Ouest, les États-Unis, le Japon aussi
qui commence à s'équiper de centrales
nucléaires
et du coup qui substitue finalement la
production d'électricité qui était au FU
par de l'électricité nucléaire. Et donc
ces pays-là, il y a aussi les réseaux
gaziers dans les villes qui se
développent et qui vont substituer le
chauffage au fiou aussi.
Les pays qui s'équipent se retrouvent
avec des excédents de fioule et du coup
toujours des de l'essence importée qui
augmenté parce que le parc automobile et
camion augmenté. Donc on augmente de
plus on importe de plus en plus de
pétrole et on se retrouve avec du fuel
disponible et donc les constructeurs se
sont dit mais il y a une possibilité
c'est utiliser ce fel en développant la
voiture la voiture diesel. Donc la
voiture diesel est partie à fond on va
dire en Europe et au Japon. Mais aux
États-Unis, les États-Unis, eux en
revanche, eux en revanche étaient
très euh très [raclement de gorge]
regardants sur la pollution. Les diesels
étaient très connus pour émettre
beaucoup de particules d'oxyde d'azote
de tout le monde. Aux États-Unis, il y
avait eu des épisodes de smogs dans les
années 60. Euh donc le smog qui venait
de l'Angleterre qui était plutôt lié au
charbon en Angleterre avec dans les
années 50 des millions de morts par
exemple en hiver dans certains épisodes
très problématiqu et puis pas tout à
fait pareil aux États-Unis un SMO qui
était plus lié aux émanations d'essence
et aux oxydees d'azote. Émanation
d'essence ont été à peu près traité au
niveau industriel carburateur des
voitures. les resté les Nox et donc par
exemple Los Angeles en Californie au
début des années 60 un jour sur de le
smog donc des manifestations partout qui
demandaient à la au dirigeants de faire
quelque chose. Donc les Américains
étaient très remontés là-dessus et donc
quand il y a eu la proposition de
développer la voiture diesel, ah non pas
du tout, ça n'est pas du tout passé aux
États-Unis et donc les États-Unis sont
restés avec leur réglementation
dont les niveaux finalement d'émission
de NOX étaient inaccessibles aux
voitures diesel. Alors qu'en Europe et
au Japon, on a créé les conditions
réglementaires en créant des colonnes
spécifiques dans la réglementation, des
colonnes plus souples permettant de
développer le le carburant diesel. Au
Japon, au milieu des années 90, il y a
eu un procès qui a été lancé par des
plaignants à Tokyo. Ils étaient
quelques-uns puis quelques centaines
rapidement qui qui a fait grand bruit
dans la presse et qui a complètement
discrédité le moteur diesel.
Même si le procès a duré 10 ans,
finalement les les constructeurs ont été
condamnés des habitants de Tokyo qui se
plaignaient d'être malades du fait qu'il
y avait des voitures diesel qui
arrivaient en grand nombre. Ils ont
gagné le procès. Mais c'est surtout le
procès lui-même qui a fait grand bruit.
Et donc finalement le le Japon qui était
parti à fond sur le diesel a retourné
complètement la situation dans le milieu
des années 90. Par contre l'Europe de
l'Ouest c'est a continué là-dedans et
est devenu finalement le champion du
monde du du moteur diesel malgré
certains rapports qui ont été enterrés
comme le rapport Rousell au début des
années 80.
Donc finalement, on se retrouve avec une
situation dans laquelle au Japon, il y a
presque pas de presque plus. En Europé,
il y en a plein et aux États-Unis, il y
en a pas du tout. Et dans les années
2000, début des années 2000, apparaît
comme technologie le filtre à particules
qui permet finalement de se dire bah les
particules, on va le traiter dans la
ligne d'échappement. Au cours des années
2000, le système de traitement des
oxydes d'azote pareil dans la ligne
d'échappement
en partie aussi sur le moteur, d'abord
développé sur les camions, puis ensuite
apparaissent sur les voitures. Et
finalement, on se dit les deux points
réglementaires qui empêchent aux
États-Unis de passer la réglementation,
je dis essence, en fait, elle est pas
spécialement essence, mais pour arriver
au niveau d'un voiture essence, bien
avec un filtre à particule et un système
de traitement des oxyde d'azote, on
commence à se dire dans les années 2000,
on doit pouvoir vendre du diesel aux
États-Unis, c'est-à-dire proposer un
véhicule clean diesel propre avec 20 %
de consommation en moins. Et donc, les
constructeurs commencent à sentir qu'il
y a un Eldoradu du diesel aux
États-Unis, donc une grosse pression
pour être le premier. celui qui sera le
premier pourra en vendre massivement. Et
euh et Volkswagen a commencé à investir
massivement la balle de industriellement
dans la perspective de pouvoir de
pouvoir diffuser du diesel le premier
donc massivement. Et il faut revenir
vers 1999 2000 en Europe. À l'époque, il
y a les premiers moteurs injection
direct qui arrivent, notamment le 3 L
diesel d'Audi euh qui lui en revanche
vibre beaucoup par rapport à des moteurs
essence qui sont installés dans ces gros
véhicules haut de gamme. Les ingénieurs
d'Audi n'arrivent pas à calmer la
vibration. C'est un diesel, ça vibre
qu'un moteur essence. Et pour un
véhicule haut de gamme, ils voulaient,
ils avaient un cahier des charges proche
du moteur essence qui ne vibrait pas
trop. il n'arrive pas à résoudre ce
problème au début des années 2000 en
Allemagne. Et comment il le résolve ? En
faisant de la postjection, c'est on est
en injection directe, on arrive à faire
plein d'injections dans le cylindre
juste avant l'explosion pour harmoniser
tout ça. Ils arrivent à calmer la
virigation comme ça. Le problème c'est
qu'en faisant toutes ces injections, ben
il passe pas du tout la norme de
dépollution. Et là les ingénieurs
commencent à se dire "Ben si on faisait
un programme, enfin un double programme
dans la calibration, c'està-dire le
calculateur moteur bien qui va
fonctionner sur un banc d'homologation
avec un moteur qui vibre, on s'en fiche
un petit peu pour le band
d'homologation.
et un moteur qui ne vibre pas ou très
peu enfin beaucoup moins dans la vraie
vie. Et à ce moment-là, ils franchissent
le Rubicon finalement de se dire "Ben,
on va faire un programme avec programme
A, programme B et finalement ça passe un
petit peu comme une lettre à la poste à
l'obologation et de 2004 à 2008 ces
véhicules sont vendus en Europe."
Le programme B, c'est là où ça crache
plein pot.
Alors, on va dire oui, comme vous
voulez, le programme A, il crache pas
mal, il vibre mais avec une détection de
cycle. C'est-à-dire finalement, c'est
assez facile en fait de détecter le
cycle. le cycle d'homologation, la
voiture, elle est sur un banc en
rouleau, c'est-àdire les roues motrices
sont entre deux rouleaux, donc le
véhicule ne bouge pas dans un local,
donc les roues pas motrice, par exemple
ne bouge pas. Or, à cette époque-là,
vous aviez déjà l'ABS et le SP sur les
voitures, donc des donc des capteurs de
vitesse sur les roues. Donc à peine la
voiture, par exemple, a démarré, vous
êtes capable de savoir si elle est dans
la vraie vie ou pas. C'est si vous avez
l'information que les roues motrices
tournent et que les autres sont fixes,
bon donc du coup, vous pouvez très
facilement. Après, vous avez le volant
aussi sur le banc d'homologation, il est
à midi pile poil puisque les rouleaux
sont perpendiculaires aux roues. Alors
que dans la vraie vie, à peine vous
démarrez, le volant il bouge un petit
peu. Donc en fait, c'est très facile en
fait de détecter le cycle. Les
constructeurs évidemment ne s'amusez pas
à ne s'amusez pas à ça.
Ils font la même chose sur les
consommations ou pas ?
Pardon ? Ils grugent aussi sur les
consommations
en même temps. Euh là non le
non le leur objectif là l' ah sur les
consommations homologuées à l'époque
l'objectif non c'était plutôt de enfin
là là là le le gros écart c'est sur la
pollue pour passer la pollue parce qu' à
l'époque il y avait pas de
réglementation sur le CO2. Euh donc j'en
reviens avec finalement ces voitures qui
roulent en Allemagne hein. Euh et donc
aux États-Unis, les ingénieurs
n'arrivent pas à passer la
réglementation américaine qui est plus
complexe à l'époque que la
réglementation européenne malgré le
filtre à particules, malgré ce système
durée parce que c'est pas si simple. Et
du coup, sous la pression du planning,
bah finalement euh décide d'utiliser la
fonction acoustique. C'est comme ça
qu'elle qu'elle s'appelait la fonction
acoustique qui qui finalement il n'avait
plus qu'à l'activer. Et et donc c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait et euh et donc la qu'ils
ont appliqué sur les moteurs diffusés à
la fois aux États-Unis mais aussi euh en
Europe. Il y en a 11 millions dans le
monde, il y en avait 500000 plus euh ils
l'ont fait sur un moteur 3 L, on va dire
presque 600000 aux États-Unis, plus de
100000 au Canada et puis en fait 11
millions dans le monde. Donc en fait, il
y en a davantage en Allemagne et et en
France que qu'aux États-Unis. Et ensuite
l'affaire, elle a éclaté. Elle a éclaté.
Et ça marche aussi sur les camions, non
? Ils font ça aussi sur les camions.
Alors, les affaires de ce qu'on appelle
Trompycle, enfin c'est 10 fit device en
anglais, c'est pas du tout la première.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, depuis les
premières réglementations de pollution,
donc on a parlé des problèmes enfin des
des triches des années 1900 1905 1910,
euh [raclement de gorge] ensuite les
premières réglementations sur la
pollution datent du début des années 70
et à l'époque dès la quasiment la
première année de la mise en place des
premières réglementations, on trouve les
premiers les premiers cas d'Autriche en
fait. Alors, les amendes, alors quand on
va parler d'amendes, euh il y a
quasiment eu aucun procès en fait, hein.
Euh pendant 40 ans, à chaque fois des
constructeurs se sont fait attraper à
justement faire deux programmes, hein.
Euh, il y a eu plein de cas hein, des
cas pourtant euh par exemple, vous avez
des véhicules qui sur l'homologation, la
climatisation n'est pas activée parce
que c'est ce qui est indiqué. Donc des
voitures quand vous n'aviez pas la clime
par exemple, ben elles étaient un peu on
va dire anémique, elle pit polluaient
pas trop et puis dès que vous mettiez la
la climatisation, ah ben là vous
retrouviez la la puissance et la
performance du véhicule et puis avec une
pollution qui s'envolait. Donc il y a
des construits qui sont fait attraper
aux États-Unis avec ça. Donc des
affaires, il y en a eu une bonne
douzaine qui n'était il y a eu très peu
de procès en fait. à chaque fois, il y a
une enquête et une négociation avec le
constructeur pour éviter le procès qui
négocie une amende. Et cette amende en
fait, il se trouve que ben ça a beaucoup
augmenté, pris plus ou moins 1-0 par
décennies et donc on avait un des
amendes qui étaient en centaines de
milliers de dollars dans les années 70
qui sont passées aux millions, dizaines
de millions, centaines de millions.
Aujourd'hui, l'affaire Volkswagen pour
Volkswagen, on a on est à presque on est
à peu près à plus de 25 milliards
d'amendes aux États-Unis
pour 500000 véhicules. pour 600000 700
on va coner le Canada avec donc à peu
près 700000 voitures, on a 25 milliards
d'amendes plus des coûts internes de
Elles ont été elles ont été rappelées
ces ces 600000 voitures
alors ces 600000 700000 600 700000
voitures, il y en a plus de la moitié
qui dorment aujourd'hui sur des immenses
parkings parce qu'en fait les rappeler
le problème c'est que si vous changez le
calculateur pour mettre le de base le
programme qui fonctionnait à
l'homologation l'ennui c'est que dans la
plupart des cas vous allez vous
retrouver avec une voiture en fait qui
n'a pas du tout les performances euh qui
ont été vendues au aux clients parce que
pour passer le test d'homologation, il y
a pas du tout besoin d'avoir deux ou 300
chevaux.
Il y en a il y en rassurez-moi les 11
millions qui sont encore dans la nature
qui sont pipés pour passer le la
réglementation, ils sont elles sont
toujours en circulation. Ben aux
États-Unis, aux États-Unis beaucoup
moins. Enfin, la partie États-Unis, non,
par contre la partie européenne, il y en
a certaines dont le calcul calculateur a
été modifié pour qu'elle pollue un peu
moins, mais elles ne sont pas du tout au
niveau au niveau normal. En revanche,
aux États-Unis, il y en a plus de la
moitié comme qui qui dorment en fait sur
des parkings depuis plusieurs années,
des immenses parkings qui sont souvent
dans des zones désertiques
qui attendent bah finalement être
réaligné. Ça ça coûterait certainement
pourquoi enfin c'est pour ça coûterait
beaucoup trop cher parce que c'est pas
juste le calculateur qui est à changé.
Pourquoi pourquoi on les enverrait pas
aux pauvres en Afrique ?
C'est c'est une question. Aujourd'hui
elles sont stationnées, il y a trois
possibilités finalement. Soit elles sont
réalignées, mais ça coûte en gros plus
cher de modifier la voiture que
finalement d'en vendre une neuve récente
au client quitte à lui rembourser la
valeur la valeur d'achat d'occasion
avant le dieselgate puisque c'est ça qui
a été évidemment négocié par les
autorités américaines.
Euh les réaligné certaines ont pu l'être
mais ça a coûté cher à Volkswagen. Et
puis ensuite celles qui sont là, bah si
on les envoie dans les pays pauvres, on
va se retrouver avec une exportation de
pollution. Exportation de pollution qui
dès aujourd'hui d'ailleurs, on peut en
parler, se produit assez massivement et
certainement de plus en plus.
Alors, on va on va parler de
l'exportation de la pollution. Après
pour les camions,
oui,
il y a eu de la gruge aussi. Il y a de
la gruge pour les camions.
Pourquoi on en parle pas ?
Mais parce que tout ça, ça s'est passé
aux États-Unis en fait essentiellement.
Euh les les la la plupart sont alors
pourquoi aux États-Unis, vous allez me
dire, alors que les voitures sont euh
sont euh ont le même programme euh qui
finalement qui est qui est qualifié de
triche officiellement aux États-Unis et
qui encore aujourd'hui euh est à l'état
et à l'état de grosse suspicion.
Est-ce que nous on a changé la
réglementation pour pouvoir les avaler
ces véhicules pour préserver de l'emploi
?
Sans sans rentrer dans le détail, j'en
serais bien incapable, des centaines de
pages des réglementations respectives
casser le thermomètre. Non, non, il y a
il y a il y a une phrase qui est
importante d'écart entre les
réglementations américaines sur ce
point-là et européennes. Euh ces
réglementations, elles indiquent bien
que euh mettre en place un programme
dans le véhicule qui euh on va dire
détourne tout le système de dépollution
de la voiture, c'est interdit. Dans les
deux cas, c'est écrit c'est interdit.
Sauf dans les deux cas, je veux dire
norme américaine européenne, c'est
interdit dans les deux cas, sauf dans
des cas de sécuris d'accident ou de
risque de sécurité, de fonctionnement du
véhicule. sous-entendu. Imaginez, vous
avez un accident, votre moteur tourne
toujours alors que je sais pas la [__]
d'accélérateur est coincée. On comprend
bien que le système, ça serait bien que
si les airbags soient déclenchés, que le
moteur s'arrête de lui-même ou alors on
s'en fiche s' pollue un peu. Là, la
priorité, c'est que ça prenne pas feu.
Enfin, on comprend bien qu'il y a des
conditions très particulières dans
lesquelles on peut s'affranchir du
système de dépollution. Ça c'est tout à
fait normal. C'est prévu dans les deux
réglementations.
La différence, c'est qu'aux États-Unis,
les conditions dans lesquelles le
programme B, si on dit que le programme
B ou le programme T, le programme triche
si vous voulez euh ou le voilà
pourquoi on l'appellerait pas le
programme escroc,
voilà ou fraude, enfin le terme voilà ou
truc trucage, je sais quoi vous voulez.
Alors, mais ça dépend de la
réglementation le terme. Bon, en tout
cas, le programme B comme vous le disiez
aux États-Unis, vous devez déclarer à
l'homologation toutes les conditions
techniques dans lesquelles le programme
B se déclencher qui est une finalement
une liste dire voilà lorsque ceci se
passe voilà et donc ça doit être
approuvé. Alors qu'en Europe, non, cette
phrase n'apparaît pas. Ce qui veut dire
qu'aux États-Unis, en fait, Volkswagen
s'est fait attraper parce que c'est pas
tellement à la limite qu'il a mis un
programme B, c'est qu'il n'avait pas
déclaré paravant que ce programme B
fonctionnait. Alors évidemment, les
conditions dans lesquelles il fait
fonctionner auraient été refusé
puisqu'il aurait dit lorsque les roues
arrières ne tournent pas, je fais
fonctionner le programme B. Évidemment,
ça aurait été refusé à l'homologation.
Mais disons que comme il n'a pas annoncé
à l'avance euh l'existence programme B
dans ces conditions-là, mais il était
forcément fautif. Alors qu'en Europe,
Alors qu'en Europe, vous pouvez toujours
arguer du fait que, enfin, c'est arguer
potentiellement du fait que ben la
raison pour laquelle vous faites
fonctionner comme ça, c'est parce que un
jour il y a eu un client qui dans cette
condition làà euh s'est retrouvé à
casser son moteur. au cas où on fait ça
c'est qu'il y a dans la réglementation
il y a aucun arbitrage demandé au
constructeur entre un éventuel souspeser
le moindre risque pour le conducteur du
risque supplémentaire de celui qui
respire les gaz d'échappement de
l'ensemble des véhicules qui sont
commercialisés. C'est pour ça que
finalement voilà c'est une triche à
verre aux États-Unis et c'est finalement
toujours un peu en suspend en Europe.
Les camions.
Oui.
Vous avez entendu des choses un peu plus
concrètes ? Ah ben il y a eu des
affaires aussi sur les camions aux
États-Unis, hein, notamment euh c'était
en 1998.
Quel constructeur ?
Ah ben à peu près tous. Il y a à un
moment, il y a une affaire où à peu près
tous se sont fait attraper.
Et sur le diesel, est-ce qu'il gruchent
?
Ah ben ils étaient ils étaient ils
étaient en diesel
et les camions étaient diesel. Mais par
exemple là sur les camions, il y a eu
des il y a eu des j'utilise d'autres
mots de vocabulaire des gruches sur le
fait que par exemple le test
d'homologation durait une vingtaine de
minutes et donc finalement certains
camions avaient des minute heures
simplement. C'est-à-dire que finalement,
on va dire, il polluit pas trop les 20
premières minutes et au bout de 21
minutes pour économiser du carburant
éventuellement de l'injection des des
systèmes durés qui permettent de traiter
les oxy d'azote, ben il commençait à
s'en affranchir histoire de de moins
embêter finalement le constructeur, le
conducteur et puis de mieux lui faire
rentabiliser son véhicule. Donc euh donc
du coup des affaires comme ça de minutur
euh vous en avez eu des des camions qui
sur autoroute fonctionnaient en vitesse
stable, pas comme sur les cycles
d'omologation pour les mêmes raisons.
Donc là grosses affaires aux États-Unis
qui ont concerné euh la plupart des
constructeurs qui ont pris des très
grosses amendes. C'était euh en 98 si je
me trompe pas. Mais des affaires comme
ça, il y en a une douzaine euh on va
dire quasiment toutes aux États-Unis,
une en Corée du Sud euh et aucune en
Europe sur ces systèmes-là de double
programmation du calculateur dans des
conditions [grognement] combien
non conformes.
Combien ça pèse l'industrie automobile
dans le monde en milliards d'euros et en
emploi ?
Alors euh moi je me suis plus préoccupé
des polluants. Alors aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le nombre de véhicules plus
précisément, on a 1 milliard 100
millions de voitures dans le monde. Bon
avec une durée de vie de 10 15 ans de
moyenne, vous faites la division voilà
et après des camions, c'est 350
millions. Des deux roues c'est un demi
milliard. Donc ça donne un marché qui
est en en dizaine de millions de de
véhicules vendus. Après en emploi, je
saurais pas vous dire combien de
pourcent exactement, mais la question
euh quelle quelle est votre question
sous-jacente ? C'est en gros est-ce que
cette pollution est justifiée par le
fait que ce sont des emplois peut-être.
C'est ça que vous voulez dire. Voilà.
Mais
raisonnons un peu comme un politicien la
question. Alors, de mon point de vue,
euh on a on a un souci sur les
transports qui n'est pas tant la nature
même de ces transports là. C'est-à-dire
finalement qu'une voiture, une voiture
euh on va dire à la limite très
confortable, puissante, c'est assez
fascinant et on va dire c'est génial un
avion euh pareil. Enfin, tous ces moyens
de transport prix individuellement sont
quand même assez extraordinaires et même
individuellement, ils ne polluent
finalement pas tant que ça. Si vous
aviez que quelques voitures dans Paris
euh comme par exemple euh ben la on
parlait de la du tournant du 20e siècle,
donc 1899,
là vous aviez énormément de chevaux dans
la ville, du crottin partout, des
épidémies de fièvre typhoïdes. Quand les
premières voitures sont arrivées, même
si tout le monde voyait qu'elle fumait,
ça a été vécu comme une bénédiction. à
la fois une bénédiction vis-à-vis de la
pollution locale par les excréments et
les animaux morts, les chevaux. Et aussi
une bénédiction parce que pour nourrir
toutes ces bêtes, ça mobilisait
énormément de pâturage. Donc en fait, il
y avait une concurrence alimentaire en
fait. OK ? Donc finalement, ces voitures
étaient peu nombreuses même si à
l'époque vous aviez des médecins qui
commençaient déjà et des chimistes à se
dire "Bon, il y en a pas trop, ça va
mais si ça se multiplie beaucoup, on va
avoir un gros souci de pollution." Et
ça, vous avez plein d'articles au début
de des années 1900, tout début. Bon euh
et donc le ce que je vous disais c'est
que voilà individuellement ces
transports finalement ils polluent pas
tant que ça. Le problème qu'on a c'est
un problème de nombre, c'est un problème
quantitatif,
il faut l'interdire.
Donc non enfin non, moi l'interdire je
vois pas l'intérêt. En revanche, notre
problème c'est un problème d'hégémonie.
On a beaucoup trop aujourd'hui. Même si
elle ne pollue individuellement,
peut-être plus tants que ça, on a
beaucoup trop de véhicules que véhicules
c'est voiture, avion en circulation. Si
on décidait par exemple de bloquer de
bloquer le parc, c'est de décider voilà
il y a 1 milliard de voitures dans le
monde, admettons un milliard, il y a
30000 avions de ligne, tant de bateaux
de de telle capacité de Pquebo, ben on
dire voilà on va bloquer le parc.
bloquer le parc, c'est bien ce qu'on a
fait en créant par exemple les cadastres
dans le domaine du logement ce que font
les Chinois avec la plaque
d'immatriculation gagnée pas tout à
fait. Les Chinois ce qu'ils font eux
c'est qu'ils ont plafonné le nombre
supplémentaire mensuel. Attention c'est
pas le nombre dans la ville, c'est le
c'est ils ont plafonné l'augmentation.
C'est en gros au lieu qu'elle soit
exponentielle, ils la font linéaire.
Voilà. Non, c'est plafonné. Comme par
exemple dans une ville, vous dites voilà
des taxis par exemple, il y en a un
nombre constant et si vous voulez être
taxi, ben il faut que vous achetiez une
licence à quelqu'un qui part à la
retraite. Donc là, ça serait on crée
l'équivalent des cadastres pour les
transports motorisés, c'estàd de décider
que si un transport neuf est acheté par
quelqu'un, c'est queil y a un transport
neuf de même capacité, avion, voiture
qui est mis à la casse. Et donc ça veut
dire qu' a finalement associé à chaque
transport, vous le possédant possesseur
aurait le droit de l'avoir comme un peu
le le foncier pour l'habitat. Donc vous
auriez le foncier mobile. Bon si on crée
cette valeur, pardon,
on peut plus faire ça.
Pourquoi ?
Napoléon l'a fait. Enfin la création des
cadastres à l'époque à l'époque
ça fait 50 ans qu'on voit aux gens que
la maison de campagne individuelle, la
voiture individuelle
euh ils vont jamais vouloir revenir.
Je reviens sur les emplois. Reviens là.
Je pour répondre à votre question sur
les emplois. Si on disait on stabilise
le parc à ce moment-là, ça veut dire
qu'en gros, je simplifie mais on
effondre par deux la production neuve.
C'est-à-dire que la production neuve,
elle sert à la fois que soit les avions,
elle sert à la fois à substituer des
véhicules vraiment, admettons HS
euh et euh et aussi à augmenter le parc.
Bon, si on se dit le parc est stable, on
va continuer à vendre des voitures
neuves en fabriquer, pas de problème.
Mais par contre, grosso modo, je
simplifie deux fois moins. Donc vous
allez me dire casse sociale énorme.
Alors, casse sociale, en terme de
conception, je vais vous dire pas
forcément parce que en terme de
conception, il y aura besoin si on prend
d'autres mesures très strictes sur la
pollution, je pense que les ingénieurs,
les techniciens de conception, ils ont
du boulot pour améliorer. Voilà. En
conception, pas forcément, en
production. Voilà. Par contre, oui. Non,
mais même vous avez en conception, vous
avez pas que des ingénieurs. Bon,
ensuite, il faut faire des prototypes et
cetera, faire des essais. Euh donc ce
que je disais, c'est que le alors par
contre, vous avez donc une case sociale
de moitié en gros de la production neuve
sous-traitant fournisseur incu. Mais en
revanche, il y a des gisements d'emploi
énormes, notamment dans l'automobile.
Dans le bâtiment, je reviens sur le cas
du bâtiment, il est parallèle
intéressant à faire. Dans le cas du
bâtiment, vous avez combien de gros
grosses catégories de métiers ? Vous en
avez trois. Vous avez la construction
neuve des bâtiments, vous avez la
réhabilitation des bâtiments, c'est
vraiment réhabilitation lourde et juste
l'entretien. Ça fait trois types de
métiers. Dans l'automobile, étrangement
dans les pays occidentaux, vous n'avez
que deux métiers. Vous avez la
production neuve et l'entretien. C'est
si vous allez au garage et vous dites
"Bon, mon moteur il est il est
vieillissant, polluant machin." Vous
allez voir votre votre maître d'œuvre,
votre architecte, "Ma chaudière est
foutue, faut la changer." Votre maître
d'œuvre ou votre plombier, il va dire
"Bon, on va acheter une nouvelle
chaudière. La votre elle a 15 ans, 20
ans, il faut la changer. Il y a les
nouvelles chaudières économes et cetera.
On va vous la changer. Éventuellement,
le circuit chauffage, on va un peu le
reprendre mais on [grognement] vous
demande pas de raser votre maison. Alors
que vous allez chez votre garagiste,
vous dites la même chose, il va vous
dire "Ah ben non, la voiture c'est
poubelle. Ah, il y a la nouvelle voiture
neuve là, celle-là là pollue pas trop."
Mais vous vous dites "Mais moi, c'est
que le moteur, mon châssis il est en
super état, je l'ai bien entretenu et
tout ça." Donc là, vous avez le marché
de la réhabilitation qui a un gisement
d'emploi colossal en quand je dis en
Europe, c'est États-Unis, Europe, c'est
en fait les plaques réglementaires dans
lesquelles en revanche ce marché là, ce
marché là dans les pays en développement
en revanche lui, il est hyper développé.
Mais par contre, c'est la foire d'
poigne. C'est vous allez dans un pays en
développement, des fois je vous mets au
défi de trouver la marque d'une voiture.
C'est que au départ, vous avez un logo
devant qui est pas forcément le même que
derrière. Vous ouvrez le moteur, il est
c'est presque un moteur de bateau dans
enfin c'est voilà. Donc du coup le train
arrière, le train avant c'est pas voilà
parce que en fait ça bricole. Alors
c'est ça crée beaucoup d'emplois de
réhabilitation dans le cré.
Voilà, ça crée beaucoup de pollution
parce que du coup c'est il y a aucune
réglementation. Donc en fait, il y a la
on a la possibilité dans les marchés
États-Unis, européens et cetera de créer
un marché de la réhabilitation qui soit
suffisamment encadré pour justement
gérer cette pollution. Et là, ça serait
un G un visier d'emploi colossal parce
qu'aujourd'hui une voiture neuve, vous
n'imaginez pas le niveau
d'automatisation qu'il y a qui fait que
du coup en fait pour une voiture neuve
et c'est ultra performant, c'est en gros
changer le moteur dans le système
d'aujourd'hui de votre voiture, ça va
vous coûter plus cher qu'une voiture
neuve effectivement parce que c'est pas
organisé pour ça. C'est pas mais si
c'était un minimum organisé
industriellement réhabiliter une voiture
si les constructeurs s'occupaient de
prévoir enfin prendre un petit moteur
moderne en remplacement sur des châssis
anciens de voitures qui ont été diffusés
à des centaines de million très conn là
là il y a du boulot je
je vous pose une question très conne.
Mais pourquoi ils l'ont pas fait avant ?
Parce que moi je dirais parce que c'est
plus parce que
parce que c'est plus simple non rapporte
je sais pas
l'obsolescence contrôlée.
Je je sais pas si ça rapporte pas ça
vous parle l'obsolescence contrôlée
probablement. Ouioui bien sûr.
Est-ce que la bagnole la bagnole est pas
passée en mode obsolisscence programmée
?
Alors je je l' alors le je vais vous en
reparler. Le truc c'est que dans la
réhabilitation du bâtiment vous avez des
entreprises qui sont spécialisées dans
la réhabilitation qui qui gagnent très
bien leur vie peut-être même à la limite
mieux que dans le neuf. Donc en fait
c'est donc finalement le marché de la
réhabitation dans l'automobile si était
organisé sérieusement pourrait très bien
être générateur de marge. Le tout c'est
que on est dans un système dans lequel
en fait on il n'existe pas. Donc je
pense que c'est plutôt par
habituation, par simplification de fait
de se dire "Bon bah il y a les garages
qui font l'entretien et les usines qui
fabri des voitures neuves." Ça serait
une remise en question colossale et des
investissements très gros si les
constructeurs se mettaient dans les
grandes villes à créer des garages
spécialisés dans la réhabitation par
exemple des moteurs et lignes
d'échappement. Pour en revenir à votre
remarque sur l'obsolescence programmée,
alors c'est intéressant parce que euh ce
débat de l'obsolescence automobile, il
date des années 20 en fait. Donc je vous
ai dit que Ford il avait Ford c'était le
dieu vivant de l'industrie donc en 1920
et lui en fait sa forté qui était son
modèle emblématique le plus vendu pour
lui la foreté il faisait de la réclame
et son et c'était de la réclame sur le
fait qu'il était solide qu'il était
endurant et on avait en face General
Motors qui lui n'avait que quelques
pourcents de part de marché n'arrivait
pas à suivre Ford techniquement et là
Général Motor s'est dit je vais lancer
deux choses pour pour me battre contre
Ford. Je vais plus me battre sur le
terrain de la solidité et cetera. Je
suis en retard, j'y arrive pas. Je vais
me battre sur deux terrains, le crédit,
donc ça c'est autre chose. Mais je vais
je vais me dire que je vais axer ma
communication sur le style et le
message. Et en l'espace de 10 ans 1920,
Ford qui avait 3/4 du marché, c'est
General Motors a pris la moitié du
marché américain en l'espace de 10 ans
simplement en ferant de la publicité en
disant voilà l'homme à la mode, l'homme
à la mode, il a telle voiture qui a tel
style et du coup on commença à
renouveler les gammes et c'est ça et
Ford ne voulait pas se lancer là-dedans.
lui il était plus puritin finalement
pragmatique
plus pragmatique plus peut-être proche
de ses clients je pense. Et donc et donc
finalement on a finalement le début de
la voiture qui est devenue finalement un
objet de mode et dans les années 50 la
la voiture américaine moyenne est-ce que
vous avez une idée neuve en moyenne au
bout de combien de temps elle était
revendue par le client ? C'était 27 mois
extraordinaire de au bout de 2 ans et
quelques toutes les voitures neuves
étaient revendues enfin en moyenne c'est
et donc à l'époque les les dirigeants de
Jeremots visaient un an en fait en gros
leur cible c'était de faire changer les
gens tous les et donc il renouvelaient
tous les ans un peu le style vous savez
avec de un petit peu plus exubérant sur
certaines lignes stylistiques et cetera
pour démoder finalement et créer une
obsolesscence programmée. Alors pour
enfin programmer dans la tête des gens
l'obsolescence l'obsolescence
programmée, je dirais le somum qui n'a
quand même heureusement pas été décidé
au moment du New Deal au début des
années 30, il y avait Bernard London qui
était un courtier américain qui avait
pour pour sortir de la récession donc
après la crise de 29 qui avait proposé
finalement au système industriel enfin
au dirigeants politiques he au président
des États-Unis
de créer de constituer une date de
péremption pour la totalité qualité des
objets industriels jusqu'à la maison
hein en passant par les voitures. Une
date de pérémtion, c'est-à-dire vous
achetez un produit, il y a une date, par
exemple pour les automobiles, il
proposait 5 ans, c'est-à-dire que au
bout de 5 ans, vous étiez tenu alors les
chaussures c'était je sais plus 12 mois,
les vêtements, les maisons c'était 25
ans. Il avait proposé une liste de
durée. Et donc si jamais vous conserviez
l'objet un peu plus longtemps, mais vous
étiez taxé enfin taxé de mauvais
citoyen, c'est-à-dire finalement parce
que vous ne faisiez pas tourner
l'industrie. Et donc il proposait qu'il
y ait des amendes pour les gens qui ne
ramenaient pas à au magasin qui leur
avait vendu l'objet le l'objet avant la
date fatidique et s'il le gardait un peu
trop longtemps et il le ramenait et et
destiné à la poubelle, pas du tout à
être revendu, à être détruit. for avait
proposé ça. Heureusement,
il a pas proposé ça pour les les
politiciens.
Ah non, c'était que pour les c'était que
pour les objets et mais d'objets de
toute taille pour la totalité
d'industrie pour garantir finalement un
niveau de production. Bon, ça n'a pas
été retenu. Le New Deal est passé par
autre chose, politique des grands
travaux. Mais finalement, c'est la mode
qui s'est chargé finalement de de
d'accélérer l'obsolescence des produits.
Excusez-moi, il y a il y a Pat qui qui
pousse des crises sur le chat, c'est
pour ça. On va on va on va vous poser
une autre question concernant les
politiques. Est-ce que vous êtes amené à
discuter avec les politiques ? Est-ce
que vous avez été amené à conseiller les
politiques ? Est-ce que vous avez été
auditionné par les politiques,
par le gouvernement, par
pour l' pour l'instant non.
Donc quand on est aux petites
associations écologistes,
pour l'instant non. Cela dit, Hervor a
été il y a plusieurs députés, sénateurs,
même un ancien ministre de l'industrie
qui ont eu lu C'est qui c'est quoi son
petit ?
Ah, je vais pas vous le dire, il m'a il
m'a adressé une lettre personnelle
extraordinaire. Euh donc, il l'a
vraiment lu dans le détail. Euh voilà
donc ce ce livre a été adressé
c'est quoi cette petite lettre ?
Elle se concluait par le
bon courage.
Non non non non non. La dernière phrase
c'était votre livre avec des
commentaires et cetera qui étaient très
sympathiques qui se terminait par votre
livre est très utile très utile souligné
signature.
Donc très content mais aujourd'hui voilà
donc en fait ce livre a été
effectivement diffusé.
J'ai dernièrement j'ai fait une
intervention à la mairie de Paris
sur le sujet de la voiture individuelle.
Il y avait qui en face ?
En face mais enfin en face à côté
plutôt, il y avait l'adjointe à
l'environnement, l'adjointe au transpé
pour faire qui vous est utilisé pour
montrer aux Parisiens retraités qui n'a
que ça à faire que d'aller écouter des
conférences très c'était organisé par un
par un journal à à la mairie de Paris,
une superbec Erica journal.
Euh et donc voilà. Donc en fait, il y a
les voilà certains politiques je sais
l'ont l'ont lu. Voilà, mais je n'ai pas
encore été auditionné.
Si si les les préconisations que vous
donnez dans votre livre ne sont pas
appliquées,
on va se retrouver dans quoi ?
Ah bah les les préconisations, bon il y
en a 40 pages, hein, ça touche la
puissance, les la nature des carburants,
les réglementations, leur transparence,
le nombre de véhicules, on en a parlé,
la notion de de patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité, des énergies fossiles. Donc
en fait, ça balaye à peu près tout.
Enfin, je de mon point de vue euh ce que
j'indique, c'est que si on lance pas à
peu près 3/4 de ça, grosso modo euh on
arrivera pas franchement à véritablement
infléchir complètement la part des
émissions de gaz à effet des transports
qui aujourd'hui est quand même un/3 au
niveau mondial hein. On entend circuler
des fois des chiffres de 15 ou 20 %. Ça
c'est juste l'émanation des de CO2 des
pots d'échappement. Et quand on
additionne les autres gaz, certains
autres gaz à effet de serre plus la
fabrication des véhicules, l'entretien,
la fabrication des infrastructures de
transport, enfin tout ça, on arrive à
1/3 des gaz à effet de serre. Au niveau
des polluants urbains, c'est de 20 à 50
% à peu près. Donc si on veut
véritablement sous 30 ans fléchir plus
qu'un fléchir et voilà, il faut lancer
3/4 de ça. Aujourd'hui, on n'y est pas
c'estàd qu'on on balbuit autour de ça.
Donc si on applique pas du tout ça, ce
qui est finalement le business asjol
d'aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire en fait on
se gargarise aujourd'hui finalement avec
un espèce de messianisme technologique.
On peut on peut en parler du fait que
aujourd'hui il y a quand même un constat
qui est complètement partagé hein euh
sur le fait que les gaz à effet de serre
augmentent le climat on envoie de plus
en plus les les les conséquences même
l'homme de la rue hein ne serait-ce que
la semaine dernière en bas on bat des
records de chaleur. [raclement de gorge]
Euh donc le l'homme de la rue maintenant
il est conscient des des premiers
dégâts. Même si au niveau politique dès
les années 70 en fait
il est conscient des dégâts mais il
continue à rouler avec sa BM. Mais lui
en fait il y a
Est-ce que l'écologie Est-ce que
l'écologie c'est pas un sport de bobo un
peu ? Enfin, il y a deux vous posez
plein de questions en même temps. Il y a
il y a deux Il y a aujourd'hui, je parle
du messianisme technologique.
Aujourd'hui, finalement je pense qu'il y
a dans la société, il y a il y a
plusieurs clivages, mais il y a
notamment un clivage entre
parmi les gens qui, on va dire, ne font
pas l'autruche. Faire l'autruche, c'est
euh les gens qui font pas l'autruche,
voilà. Mais qui se disent qui se disent
enfin qui disent "Oui, il y a vraiment
un problème. Le climat est en train de
se déréguler parce que les gaz effet
augmentent. Il y a des énormes dégâts
sanitaires, accident cardioovasculairire
et cetera à cause des particules, des
oxydes d'azote et puis le plomb." Alors
le plan qui commence à à sortir de
l'essence quand même depuis un depuis
quelques années dans les pays
occidentaux. Mais bon, on a un grave
problème qui est le problème, il est
constaté aujourd'hui. Il y a plus débat
sur cette question. La question c'est
pour le réseau là, vous avez un clivage
en gros entre deux types de personnes.
Ceux qui se disent et puis alimenté par
finalement un certain fatalisme. Alors
le fatalisme, il y en a deux ordres
hein. Il y a le fatalisme qui est on est
foutu, on y arrivera pas. Bon bah du
coup le climat va partir en vrac et
cetera. Bon je vais tenter de survivre.
Alors soit je survis en essayant d'en
mettre un maximum à gauche pour ma
famille, soit j'essaie de survivre en me
construisant un bunker et en mettant des
raviolis en mettant des raviolis dans le
bunker.
Vous avez oublié la troisième mais ça
alors il y a le ce fatalisme là et il y
a un autre fatalisme finalement qui lui
est alimenté par le fait de se dire non
il y a rien à faire dans nos modes de
vie. Il y a tellement de de
d'ingénieurs, de chercheurs qui bossent.
Ah oui, là il y a telle application,
dans quelques années, ça va passer dans
le domaine dans ça va se déployer en
masse. Donc c'est le métianisme
technologie qui consiste à penser que
finalement on a rien à changer nos modes
de vie et euh finalement il ne suffit
qu' que d'attendre un petit peu, pas
longtemps que telle technologie se
développe et le problème va se résoudre
de lui-même. Et finalement ces deux
fatimz se rejoignent finalement dans le
business. Et le business aujourd'hui,
les tendances c'est que en fait ça
conduise à un à un climat de plus plus
plutôt + 5°gr à la fin du siècle. Bon
là, on sera peut-être plus là nous mais
pour nos enfants. Mais quelle quelle
planète on va laisser à nos enfants ne
serait-ce qu'en 2050 ?
Ah b on pourra vivre sous terre.
Oui. Non non on vivra quand même. Mais
quelle dérive on est en train de mettre
en place ? Donc je pense que c'est ces
ces mesures là si on si on ne prend pas
la mesure, je sais pas par exemple
aujourd'hui la loi sur les mobilités par
exemple aujourd'hui je pense
comment vous voyez la mobilité individu
individu aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas qu'on fasse
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui je pense
c'est une erreur de diagnostic en fait
l'erreur de diagnostique on en a un
petit peu parlé c'est de faire croire
par exemple qu'avec des transports plus
rapides par exemple on va faire gagner
du temps aux gens
hyperloupe c'est du bullshit
Mais l'hyperloupe en fait alors parce
puisque la réalité c'est que en fait on
rallonge les distances question internet
mais moi j'invite les gens qui
s'interrogent sur l'Hperloupe à lire le
texte fondateur de l'Herloupe. Est-ce
que vous le connaissez ? Le texte
fondateur mais en fait il est pas si
récent c'est le livre d'Albert Robida le
20e siècle écrit en 1883.
Et ce livre, bon, il y a pas le mot
hyperloupe dedans, mais il y a
l'hyperloupe dedans. Et il est à plein
de pages parce que donc c'est un livre
d'anticipation euh oui, un roman
d'anticipation écrit en 1883. Robida
c'est donc un contemporain de de Jul
Verne euh qui était plus connu pour ses
caricatures mais qui qui était aussi un
romancier. Et cet ouvrage qui a qui qui
a eu du succès he à l'époque le 20e
siècle et en fait il se projette en
1953. Oui, lui il fait un donc Wells
avait fait un saut de 100 ans, lui il
fait un saut de 70 ans et en fait il
décrit la vie d'étudiante qui passe le
bac voilà dans les années 1952 53 et lui
il estime qu'à cette époque-là en fait
il y aura des transports très rapides
entre les villes et et ces transports
interville c'est que de l'hyperloupe en
fait que de que des que des tuyaux
pressurisés dans lesquels les véhicules
circulent à plus de 1000 km/h. Donc
vraiment exactement l'hyperloope. Et
donc ce qui est intéressant en lisant ce
livre, c'est de voir un petit peu quel
est l'état d'esprit de la population
autour de ça et notamment cette histoire
de rallongement des distances. Voilà.
Euh donc ça c'est intéressant et puis il
y a d'autres intérêt de se livre sur les
transports d'ailleurs, c'est que à
l'époque 1883, il y a pas du tout les
premiers avions. Clémenter a pas encore
volé ni les frères White. Donc en gros,
les futurologues jusqu'à la fin du 19e,
l'avion ça existe pas pour eux sauf un
horizon très lointain même pour WS en
1900. Et donc ils imaginent beaucoup
plus des choses autour des dirigeables.
Donc en fait c'est intéressant de voir
Robida qui voyait finalement les
liaisons entre les villes de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres avec que des que
des hyperloupes pour prendre le langage
moderne. Et à l'intérieur des villes,
les transports en commun les plus
efficaces qui étaient finalement
relativement lents mais assez rapides
parce que direct c'était des noria en
fait de dirigeable de toute table de
toute taille depuis le dirigeable
individuel jusqu'au dirigeable
collectif. C'est en train de revenir
avec Google. Voilà. Donc le d'ailleurs
en France,
alors là, on parle pas de drone tout ça
hein, c'est c'est c'était des véhicules
finalement relativement lents. Bon euh
alors enfin voilà donc les voilà je
pense que voilà sur les gens qui se
posent des questions sur l'Herloupe,
c'est intéressant qu'il lise le 20e
siècle de Robida pour voir en fait que
ben on retomberait dans ce qu'on a dit
de Charbonau tout à l'heure c'estàd que
finalement une ville du centre de la
France par exemple imaginons Limoche he
qui s'interroge là-dessus si elle était
à 1 heure de Paris avec un hyperloupe
alors je vous parle pas de de du
chantier d'infrastructure parce que à la
vitesse à laquelle c'est censé circuler
les virages les rayons de courbure
seront encore plus grands que ceux du
TGV. Donc sous-entendu des des
infrastructures très importantes. Mais
si c'est à 1 heure de Paris, bah
l'imoge, ça va devenir la 7e couronne de
Paris. C'est un peu comme Malo qui a vu
le prix de l'immobilier éclaté euh quand
on a vu le TG
finalement les et donc il y a une partie
des emplois qui vont se des emplois qui
aujourd'hui certes un peu enclavés dans
ces zones-là vont se retrouver
finalement euh une espèce de un espèce
de néocolonialisme
intérieur euh de banlieu lointaine que
seront devenues les villes provinciales
une fois connectées à Paris en moins
d'une heure.
Alors c'est bien ou c'est pas bien ? Ben
non, ça c'est pas que c'est c'est en
fait ça sert à rien, c'est juste ça.
C'est quoi la mobilité ? La ville du
futur,
la ville du futur, si on veut qu'elle
soit euh à la fois résiliente et moins
émétrice, il faut se réinterroger
finalement. Le diagnostic étant que plus
on a mis en masse aux gens des voitures
des voitures enf des des moyens de
transport, pas que la voiture, des
moyens de transport motorisé pas cher,
plus ils ont rallongé les distances. Là,
on parle de la voiture, mais c'est
pareil pour l'avion. C'est-à-dire que
finalement le dépaysement que vous aviez
il y a une cinquantaine centaine
d'années à une certaine distance. Bon,
on peut revenir même à la limite à
Montigne mais bon qui qui à peine il
faisait 200 km, il se retrouvait avec un
dépaysement total avec des gens qui
parlaient même plus la même langue, qui
mangeaient plus du tout la même chose,
qui s'habillaient plus pareil et cetera.
Et finalement, au fur et à mesure qu'on
a mis en plat des transports rapides et
massifs, bon marché, en fait, on éloigne
le dépaysement.
C'est je reprends puisqueon pensait à à
Charbonau qui disait que l'avion a fait
de papette notre Nice. Voyez ?
C'està-dire que finalement le dépisement
que vous aviez à allez 1000 km il y a 50
ans, il y a 25 ans il était à 3000 km.
aujourd'hui, il faut faire peut-être
10000 km pour l'avir.
Donc finalement, en gros, mettre en
place des transports rapides,
historiquement, ça laisse croire aux
gens que ça va être mieux, mais ça n'est
que mieux finalement si ça reste si ça
reste anecdotique. Et donc
malheureusement là, il y a une une
discourdence sociale, enfin une
discrimination sociale parce que si un
transport très rapide ne concerne que
quelques-uns, donc grosso modo en fait,
il est très cher pour ces gens-là,
effectivement ça représente un gain de
temps. On peut parler par exemple du
supersonic, des choses comme ça. Mais
par contre si on si on dit aux gens oui,
d'abord c'est pour les millionnaires,
milliardaires, mais ne vous inquiétez
pas, l'industrie va faire d'énormes
progrès,
ça va russer,
ça sera pour vous bientôt. Mais ça mais
ça ça c'est une illusion.
Ruissellement, c'est une illusion.
Et oui, c'est une illusion parce qu'une
fois que ça ruisselle, ça rallonge la
distance et c'est et donc c'est une
illusion. C'est étonnant de voir par
exemple, allez, si on parle de ben tiens
en roman d'anticipation, on peut parler
de du meilleur des mondes d'UXley au
début des années 30. Au même moment,
vous aviez Breget, donc Louis Breget qui
était spécialiste de la conception des
hélicoptères et qui était constructeur
d'avion
et de tables. Il fait des très bonnes
tables.
Ah, ça je savais pas. Alors donc lui
Brigeté dans les années 30, lui il est
persuadé en fait que ses enfants,
petits-enfants connaîtront la la voiture
volante.
Connaîtront de leur vivant la voiture
volante pour tous he pas pour ces
enfants millionnaires, pas du tout hein.
Ces petits-enfants eux leur véhicule ça
sera un véhicule volant capable de voler
à 3 400 km/h. Voilà avec des systèmes
repliables et tout ça pour ensuite
circuler juste enfin dans le quartier où
ils habitent et se garer comme une
voiture. Alors des expériences avaient
été faites sur ce sujet là par exemple
alors les premières c'est c'est Tempier
juste à la sortie du premier conflit
mondial là vous avez René Tempier qui
avait circulé dans Paris avec un avion
donc un espèce de biplan 191920 par là
donc un espèce de biplan dont les ailes
se repliaient et qui avait des roues et
donc en fait il était capable de enfin
il roulait dans Paris avec et il
écartait ses ailes, il décollait et
voilà donc l'ennui c'est que c'était à
la fois un mauvais avion, une mauvaise
voiture parce qu'alourdi par les par les
deux par les deux cahiers des charges et
en fait il a pas réussi à vendre son
concept, ça a pas marché mais dans les
années 50 vous aviez des des des enfin
je dire start-up c'est le vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui mais des oui des
équivalents de start-up qui commençaient
à envisager de mettre sur le marché de
nouveau des voitures volantes à la un
petit peu comme Bregel imaginé dans les
années 50 avec certaines c'était le
fuselage que vous démontiez et en fait
vous avez une voiture qui était capable
de de rouler à 150
à l'heure. Voilà, vous posiez le
muselage, le fuselage à l'aérodrome et
puis vous aviez votre voiture. Voilà.
Nous,
on va retourner à la [__]
Pardon ?
Nous, on va retourner à la [__]
c'est-à-dire
la force musculaire.
Ah oui, mais alors effectivement une
question qui se pose sur alors il y a le
mienologique d'un côté les modes de vie.
Donc ceux qui pensent qu'il faut
vraiment questionner complètement nos
modes de vie. Questionner de mode de
vie, ça veut dire nos moyens de
transport, notre nos possibilités d'y
avoir accès pour pas cher. On a parlé de
la voiture facile, l'avion et cetera.
Euh et effectivement se reposer la
question de finalement renchérir les
transports. Alors évidemment le gilet
jaune quand quand si si je lui dis ben
votre voiture en fait ben vous l'achetez
20000 € mais votre maison quand vous
enfin votre appartement vous avez bien
payé les fondations. Donc finalement
votre voiture enfin la voiture qu'on
vend pourquoi on payerait pas les
fondations avec c'està-dire au lieu de
l'acheter 20 je sais pas 9 20 30000 €
mais on l'a pé le double parce qu'il
faudrait faudrait payer la côte part de
bitum et d'enrobé et de route qui lui
correspond au prata de de de
l'infrastructure sur laquelle elle roule
à peu près. À ce moment-là, grosso modo,
vous pourriez d'embler doubler le prix
des véhicules. Voilà, quand vous achetez
une maison, vous payez pas que la
superstructure posée par posé sur une
dalle en béton et des fondations payées
par la collectivité. C'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe. Donc déjà le prix
renchéri on va dire la voiture deux fois
plus chère à l'achat et puis on a dit
les carburants ben plus chers pour
financer la sécurité sociale, tout ce
qu'on a raconté. Donc commencer à dire
que l'essence est à 3 € le litre, c'est
sûr que bon tout de suite aïe aïe aïe
grosse catastrophe pour les gens qui se
sont installés dans les situations
effectivement où ils avaient une
équation économique avec 1,20 € plus la
voiture d'occasion euh effectivement
c'est un grave problème. Et par contre
cet argent-là, ça veut dire que l'État
ben du coup tirera finalement ses
ressources des des usagers et donc ça
dégage une baisse d'impôts. Par contre,
le tout c'est que la baisse d'impôts et
le financement supplémentaire comme
l'État, il faudra que provisoirement et
se provisoirement pour pas mal de gens
devra devra s'appliquer justement aux
mêmes personnes qui voient tout d'un
coup le prix de l'essence flambé à la
station service.
Ça ça marche que dans vos rêves ça va
jamais se passer comme ça.
Ça s'est déjà passé comme ça
où
Ah mais en temps en temps de ben déjà
euh il y a eu des confinements. Il y a
eu en temps de guerre en temps de guerre
Nicolas Hul dit en temps de guerre en
guerre pas qu'en temps de guerre
reprenez ce qui s'est passé au moment
des chocs pétroliers les chocs
pétroliers de 73 79
alors moi j'ai moi j'étais petit mais
alors il y avait il y avait quand même
donc très forte augmentation du prix de
l'essence alors à l'époque je dirais
heureusement elle était très taxée donc
comme elle était taxée à 3/4 finalement
un triplement du prix du pétrole donc il
est passé en donc Noël, cadeau de Noël
73. Enfin, en fait, c'est en quelques
semaines, hein, mais cadeau de Noël 73,
le prix du baril passe de 3 à 12
dollars. Bon,
il y a combien aujourd'hui ?
Alors, aujourd'hui, j'ai pas vérifié
hier, mais on va dire 60 70, je sais
plus, quelque chose comme ça. Donc, il
passe de 3 à 12. Il est passé ensuite de
mémoire de 14 à 30 en 79. Bon, donc
finalement le prix de l'essence a pris
plusieurs dizaines de pour tout de suite
ouh là là les gens se sont mis à tout de
suite les constructeurs à proposer des
voitures plus légères. Alors ça ça n'a
duré qu'un temps. C'est si on regarde le
poids, la puissance des voitures, il y a
des inflexions qui correspondent
justement à ces périodes là où
de récession économique
de alors de de récession énergétique si
vous voulez, on va dire
et donc économique.
Voilà. Alors qui a conduit à des
récessions économiques effectivement
parce que le système était pas préparé à
ça. On va dire ça comme ça. Il était pas
était pas résilient. il était pas
résilient ou ou simplement le PIB est en
fonction de notre consommation
énergétique. Non.
Euh oui oui oui. Spécialiste plus qu'on
est toujours sorti de crise financière
par une surconsommation énergétique
par ou par une relance Oui. par une
espèce de relance des infrastructures et
consommation. Euh mais par exemple sur
les Alors sur
une question de Ali que pensent-il des
vélos électriques avec euh quelque
assistance que ce soit ?
Alors en fait la la question du moyen
c'est c'est un peu comme la question
qu'est-ce que vous pensez d'une voiture
électrique ? En fait la question c'est
vélo électrique vélo électrique
oui mais c'est la même. C'estàd ce que
je veux dire c'est que
est-ce que c'est finalement c'est pas la
question n'est pas tellement le vélo
lui-même, c'est la personne qui est
dessus et l'usage qu'elle en a.
C'est-à-dire que finalement, si c'est
quelqu'un qui faisait du vélo euh du
vélo mécanique, enfin avec la fibre
musculaire et puis qui se dit "Ah ben
tiens, le le vélo électrique c'est pas
mal, c'est plus sympa, je vais faire les
mêmes trajets en me dépensant un peu
moins." Bon ben à à ce moment-là, le
vélo électrique, si vous faites ça dans
toutes les situations que tous si tous
les vélos mécaniques se transforment en
vélo électrique, ça va pas être une
bonne chose. En revanche, dans le sens
contraire, si quelqu'un se dit "J'allais
au domicile [__] enfin je sais mon
domicile travail ou mes courses, je sais
pas avec ma voiture, il n'existe pas,
c'est le vélo, je peux pas le prendre
parce qu'il y a des côtes, c'est trop
loin." Tout à fait. Et là, le vélo
électrique apparaît sur le marché et
cette personne-là achète un vélo
électrique pour substituer des trajets
finalement polluants à là à ce
moment-là. Alors pourant c'est le même
vélo et ma réponse c'est pas du tout la
même. Donc c'est pas tellement sur ces
sur ces véhicules électriques. Vous
pouvez parler pareil de la trottinette
du vélo, de la voiture. La question
c'est est-ce qu'on est en addition de
déplacement ? Est-ce qu'on est en
substitution de déplacement ? Et si on
est en substitution de déplacement par
rapport à quoi ? Par rapport à quel type
de déplacement ? Et puis a même la
voiture autonome, c'est encore un sujet.
C'est les le fameux effet rebond.
Oui, exactement. C'est c'est le fameux
effet rebond. Par exemple, une voiture
électrique qui est euh qui fait un petit
peu la la tête de gondole aujourd'hui
euh de de certains salons, c'est la
voiture électrique autonome
ou de politique gouvernementale.
Voilà. de politique gouvernementale
qui euh bah qui déploie tout pour que la
voiture autonome s'installe chez soi.
Les infrastructures, il faut bien
rappeler les infrastructure automobile,
les grosses he je veux dire, elles ont
été vraiment lancées par les
gouvernements pas du tout au départ pour
satisfaire une demande une demande je
veux dire une demande civile. les
premières par exemple grosses
infrastructures autoroutières qu'ell soi
première tout au tout départ italienne
mais allemande allemande américaine
c'était dans des buts militaires en fait
donc on a lancé des infrastructures
massivement par l'État et pour la
voiture autonome la question c'est
finalement aujourd'hui elle est
présentée comme finalement elle va pas
trop polluer parce que c'est de
l'écoconduite elle va jamais en plus
avoir d'accident génial mais la voiture
autonome en fait même si elle est
électrique la question c'est est-ce
qu'elle est en substitution de
déplacement C'est-à-dire qu'en fait,
est-ce que c'est un est-ce que le trajet
qui sera fait dans 10 ans par une
voiture autonome menant telle personne
d'un point A à un point B, si elle
n'existait pas, est-ce que la même
personne aurait pris sa voiture pour
faire le même trajet ? Si c'est le cas,
à la limite, pourquoi pas ? Mais à mon
avis, c'est pas ça qui va se passer. Ce
qui va se passer, c'est que je pense
majoritairement, on en reparle dans 10
ans, majoritairement, je pense que les
trajets des voitures autonomes, ce sont
des trajets supplémentaires. Par
exemple, vous voyez là un typiquement un
effet rebond potentiellement
dévastateur. Et je pense que la voiture
autonome, ça peut être la la quelque
part presque potentiellement ça les
gènes de la pire catastrophe automobile
à venir. Donc le c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
vous allez donner la possibilité de
rentrer dans des voitures tout seul des
gens qui n'ont pas le permis, par
exemple des enfants, des jeunes. Non,
mon fils ne va pas à l'école à pied ou
en trottinette, c'est trop dangereux, je
te commande une voiture autonome tous
les matins. D'ailleurs, la carte
scolaire, l'école à côté, ah non,
l'école qui est à 5 km, elle est très
réputée. Sans voiture autonome, non, je
t'inscris à côté mais là, je te commande
une voiture autonome tous les matins, tu
tu iras là-bas. Donc ça, les personnes
âgées qui veulent aller voir leur leurs
neveux faciles qui ne conduisent plus.
Ah, ils vient pas me voir, je vais aller
le voir. Hop, une voiture autonome.
Les trajets très très longs. Euh vous
pouvez avoir des trajets notamment aux
États-Unis. Euh vous pouvez dire "Ah
non, ce trajet c'est à 600 km, j'y vais
pas parce que je dois louer une voiture,
prendre un avion. Non, allez, on laisse
tomber là." Ah ben non, une voiture
autonome, je la commande à 10h du soir.
Je prends l'option couchage et je me
réveille le lendemain matin, petit
déjeuner au lit, frais, dispo, livré
comme un paquet. euh à destination. Donc
là là là, vous avez potentiellement un
effet rebond colossal. Voilà, l'effet
rebond de Jevens qui date de des
locomotives et des machine à vapeur du
du 19e siècle.
Alors, c'était un peu court. Euh on
arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Ah euh on va vous poser euh quelques
questions encore. On va vous on va vous
poser notre fameuse dernière question
qui est laissé qui n'est pas une
question qui est laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Oui. Oui.
Quelque chose d'impérissable.
D'accord. Euh on vous laisse y réfléchir
et on va prendre quelques questions de
de l'internet si on se fait pas spammer.
Alors sur la mobilité à 100 ans, on l'a
déjà on l'a déjà abordé. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez des moteurs thermiques dopés
à l'eau ?
Ah oui, alors euh la la question est
assez bonne parce que si on dit "Que
pensez-vous des moteurs à eau, là c'est
déjà plus ambigu." Alors les moteurs à
haut pantone, c'est ça.
Voilà par exemple. Donc voilà, l'eau
l'eau l'eau l'eau n'étant pas un
carburant, il faut pas rêver sur le fait
que qu'on puisse avoir un moteur à e
haut. Alors des moteurs à e haut pour
être plus précis, il y en a quand même
eu. Il y avait des tramoué. Alors je p
c'est les années 1870 donc vraiment
voilà en plein cœur des tramoués qui des
tramoués à l'époque les tramoué c'est
pas comme aujourd'hui hein des tramoués
très longs hein. Les tramoué c'était une
un seul wagon enfin c'était voilà et
donc il était équipé de de bou de
bouillotte à 200°. Donc en fait, on
faisait chauffer cette bouillotte au
Terminus, enfin au Terminus au départ,
on l'a monté à 200° alors avec du
charbon ou et puis finalement c'était un
moteur à haut parce qu'en fait il
lâchait, il était capable de rejoindre
l'autre terminus avec un moteur à haut
finalement. Mais mais en fait l'eau
n'était pas un carburant. Le carburant
c'était qu'en fait arriver au terminus,
il fallait remonter à 200° le pour qu'il
revienne dans le sens. Donc c'est un
donc ça être ce type de moteur à eau.
Après les vous avez les moteurs à
hydrogène mais l'hydrogène il faut
certains disent c'est un moteur à eau
mais en fait il faut fabriquer
l'hydrogène avec l'électrolyse de l'eau
et il faut de l'énergie pour ça. Après
ce qui est réel c'est le fait que euh
sous certaines conditions le
fonctionnement d'un moteur en lui
rajoutant de l'humidité dans le mélange.
Typiquement, vous pouvez même en
mesurant précisément ça partant de
brouillard se rendre compte alors des
capteurs précis que vous pouvez
éventuellement économiser un petit peu
de carburant et même émettre un petit
peu moins d'oxyde d'azote en injectant
de la vapeur c'est quelques pourc hein
l'ennui alors ça ça du coup ça serait un
petit peu d'économie de carburant c'est
tout à fait réel l'ennui c'est que vu
d'un constructeur c'est un réservoir un
réservoir d'eau assez significatif à
rajouter sur la voiture. Donc c'est du
poids et surtout de la place. Si vous
ouvrez les voitures d'aujourd'hui, c'est
un spaghetti dans le coffre moteur,
allez trouver un réservoir, une zone
pour mettre un bidon d'eau que vous
allez remplir régulièrement, ce qui se
posera peut-être pas trop de problème.
De l'eau, on en trouve un peu partout
mais donc pour pouvoir injecter
régulièrement de l'humidité et tenter de
faire un réglage qui va gagner
effectivement quelques pourcoup
supplémentaire de la place, du poids. Et
puis ensuite le deuxième sujet, c'est
rajouter en permanence de l'umidité de
l'humidité dans des cylindres qui sont
quand même globalement métalliques, si
vous voulez, vis-à-vis de la durabilité.
C'est une question. Et puis après les
nouveaux moteurs modernes, ils sont à
injection directe. Et là et là
l'injection directe injectée de l'eau,
je le sens pas très bien. Ça serait
plutôt pour des moteurs plus anciens qui
sont à carburateur en fait où là vous
avez un mélange carburant R dans
laquelle on peut éventuellement injecter
un peu d'eau.
Question de notre ami Exoset. Comment
connaître le bilan énergétique global
d'un véhicule ?
Le bilan énergétique global, moi je
pense que la la question n'est plus le
bilan énergétique global. Je pense que
déjà la question c'est le bilan carbone
global parce que alors certes
effectivement pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre, il est temps de
réduire fortement les consommations
d'énergie. C'est c'est le premier levier
mais c'est pas le seul. Donc je pense
que faire un bilan si vous voulez en
kilowh OK d'énergie primaire ou ce que
vous voulez du véhicule à la fois je
pense que ça a pas tellement de sens. Ça
avait du sens pendant tout le 20e siècle
où en fait depuis les années 10 il y
avait des craintes sur le fait qu'on
manque de pétrole dans les 20 ou 30 ans
à venir. Et ça ça a été très régulier
depuis les années 10 hein de 1910. Et
puis après, il y a eu des découvertes.
Ensuite, ça a été les aujourd'hui les
réserves non conventionnelles qui font
que finalement on a toujours 30 ou 40
ans devant nous. Euh mais bon, dans une
logique de pénurie énergétique à terme,
je comprends qu'on fasse des calculs en
bilan énergétique. Donc je répondrai
plutôt à la question qui est pas loin,
c'est quel est le bilan carbone
aujourd'hui d'une voiture laquelle ? Peu
importe. En ordre de grandeur sur sur
100, sur toute sa vie, il faut
considérer qu'une voiture thermique,
c'est 15. Allez, je veux dire 15 pour
fabriquer la voiture moyenne, 15 pour
l'infrastructure en fait la côte part de
l'infrastructure à étendre et entretenir
et 70 en gros c'est ce qui sort du pot
d'échappement. Voilà, ça c'est une
voiture thermique moyenne européenne
d'aujourd'hui. C'est à peu près ça. Et
du coup autour de ça, bah si elle est
électrique par exemple, bah le 15 de
départ, bon les infrastructures en gros
c'est les mêmes. Le 15, le 15 de la
fabrication bah il va se prendre 50 % à
cause de la batterie. Donc elle passé à
22, toute chose égale par ailleurs, 22
23. Et du coup le 70, lui qu'est-ce
qu'il devient ? Et là la grosse question
c'est comment on fabrique l'électricité
supplémentaire ? Et là vous pouvez avoir
tous les résultats possibles. C'estàd
que si c'est que des centrales au
charbon, vous mettez votre voiture en
graisse par exemple, ça va être que des
centrales au charbon vous allez
suractiver pour pouvoir recharger votre
voiture, vous allez exploser le
compteur.
Question internet. Les biocarburants
ont-ils un meilleur bilan carbone que
l'essence si on tient compte de tout le
cycle de vieation. Alors les
agrocarburants alors déjà en gén alors
ça dépend lesquels et les biocarburants
c'est assez compliqué ça dépend lesquel.
Alors déjà il y a l'histoire aussi il y
a pas que le bilan carbone à regardé il
y a la notion de terre arable et de la
concurrence alimentaire. Vous vous
souvenez de ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure sur les chevaux avec l'arrivée
des premières voitures. C'est une
bénédiction. Tous ces chevaux à nourrir
ils vud mieux nourrir la population
plutôt que les chevaux qui servent à
transporter les gens et les
marchandises. Ça va nous libérer des
terres. C'est marrant parce
qu'aujourd'hui 100 ans plus tard, on se
met à se reposer la même question. Si on
développe à fond les agrocarburants qui
représentent euh aujourd'hui à peu près
3 % du carburant routier, euh c'est des
agrocarburants, et bien on commence à se
dire "Ah ben il faut développer les
agrocarburants parce que comme ça c'est
renouvelable." Et du coup on retombe
dans le même euh dans le même travers
qu'il y a 100 ans à se dire "Mais
attends, on va affamer la planète s'il
est 97 % autre, on cherche à aller
fabriquer des aocarburants." Donc ça
c'est ça c'est le premier sujet. Ensuite
il y a les il y en a plein des
arocarburants. L'huile de palme c'est
une catastrophe. Aujourd'hui, il y a une
partie du biodiesel
en pourcentage, c'est de l'huile de
palme.
Du biodiesel, c'est pas tout ça. Bio et
diesel en terme de vocabulaire sur les
carburants, là il y aurait il y aurait
tout à reprendre de zéro. Je vous dis
tout de suite parce que ce qu'on appelle
biocarburant déjà ils sont pas du tout
bio parce que parce que derrière c'est
des engrais chimiques des p tout ça.
Ad blue, vous connaissez Ad Blue ? Oui.
Sû. Alors les les alors alors les les
vous avez donc les agrocarburants, ils
sont pas du tout bio parce que c'est de
l'engr chimique et cetera. Voilà, donc
c'est pas c'est l'agriculture
industrielle pour les fabriquer en les
produire pardon. D'un autre côté
finalement l'essence et le gazol après
tout
c'est bio.
C'est presque bio parce que c'est la
Terre qui les a fabriqué il y a quelques
alors dizaines de millions d'années ou
centaines de millions d'années dans le
sous-sol. Cuisson sous pression,
maturation et cetera. Voilà, nous on les
sort. Bon, en les raffinant, c'est plus
très bio. Bon, ça n'est quand même pas
très loin. Il y a quelques additifs là,
ils sont pas bio. Mais disons queen
fait, si on parlait de biocarburant, en
fait, l'essence et le gazol sont
beaucoup plus bio. Enfin, le biodiesel,
ça devrait être le diesel, le gazol, en
fait. Voilà, donc déjà en terme de
vocabulaire, on est à moitié perdu mais
bon. Donc les biocarburants, tel qu'on
les appelle aujourd'hui, on devrait les
appeler agrocarburant finalement mais
eux il y en a plein de catégories. Et
sur, on va dire le moins mauvais, on va
dire comme ça, concurrence alimentaire,
par exemple le maïs aux États-Unis. Donc
l'éthanol américain, donc Amérique du
Sud, très développé en Amérique du Sud,
c'est surtout la canne à sucre. Aux
États-Unis, c'est surtout le maïs. Il y
a quand même 30 % du maïs américain. Et
le le maïs américain, c'est quand même
du très vaste. 30 % qui est destiné à
faire de l'éthanol routier. 30 %. Donc
si on voulait augmenter ça, vous
imaginez le le le le dégâts. Alors là,
normalement l'éthanol lui, c'est au bout
de quelques années dans les calculs
alors hors concurrence alimentaire et
tout ça que vous allez que le changement
d'affectation des terres, c'est-à-dire
le fait de finalement transformer une
prairie qui avait du stock de carbone et
tout ça, libérer ce carbone là, petite
forêt des arbres, des on libère ce
carbone pour planter, admettons du maïs
qui sert à faire de l'éthanol. Mais du
coup, en fait, il va falloir plusieurs
années, mais à priori moins d'une
décennie pour que finalement euh
l'évitement euh de CO2 émi euh du fait
finisse par rembourser le changement
d'infectation des sols que vous avez
fait au départ. Par contre, l'huile de
Palme, vous en sortez jamais.
On a vu que c'était un sujet qui est
compliqué, surtout pour les politiciens.
C'est difficile de répondre en une
minute à vos questions. Bon, entre vous
et nous, on va au carton au niveau de la
pollution ? Ah moi je pense que si si on
continue à à faire des mesurettes et à
rester dans le messianisme
technologique, moi je pense
qu'effectivement on va on va au casspip.
Mais c'est pas grave.
Pourquoi ?
On va se faire de la recherche. On va
faire de la recherche génétique. On va
avoir un troisème poumon
et puis et puis on aura on sera tous
transhumains.
C'est étonnant parce que dans les années
dans les années 60 aux États-Unis, je
vous parlais du fait que la pollution de
l'air c'était très très présent et c'est
pour ça que donc le diesel ne s'est pas
développé. Dans les, il y avait quand
même des articles de presse sur Newsweek
aux États-Unis où les gens se disaient
"Mais si ça continue, si on ne fait rien
euh mais il va falloir qu'on s'équipe de
masque à gaz." Quand je parle de masque
à gaz, c'est pas juste le petit tissu
blanc euh devant le visage, ça filtre
tout. C'est des véritables masques à
gaz. Et donc, je me souviens d'un
article enfin que j'avais retrouvé, vous
voyez les gens qui roulaient en voiture
sur les décapotables avec des masques à
gaz, les piétons qui se promènent avec
des cartouches comme ça de masque à gaz.
Et donc si à l'époque il y avait les
OGM, je je pense qu'à l'époque ils
auraient fait des desserts avec des gens
avec des je sais pas moi des poumons euh
des poums euh greffé à l'extérieur. H
euh Oui. Ou dérivé de cochon OGM ou je
sais pas quoi euh pour mais de poumons
qui sont capables eux de
vite fait le l'air comprimé les voitures
à air comprimé.
Oui oui ben les voitures à air comprimé
bon la question pareil c'est comment on
comprime l'air c'estàd avec quelle
énergie on va le comprimer. Donc ça
c'est un premier sujet. Donc si c'est
euh de l'électricité au charbon, un
machin et cetera, bon euh bah la réponse
que c'est pas terrible. Euh mais l'air
comprimé c'est c'est intéressant mais la
réserve est faible. C'estàd c'est
intéressant pour des petits véhicules
légers urbains. Euh je trouve ça assez
assz un concept assez intéressant. Alors
il faut faire attention finalement à la
manière dont on va enfin quelle énergie
on va utiliser pour assurer la
compression en amor du véhicule. Voilà.
évidemment, mais mais c'est un concept
intéressant parce que je pense
contrairement à la batterie où il y a le
risque que le progrès technique fasse
qu'on atteigne la capacité énergétique
des carburants liquides et que du coup
ben on arrête de se poser la question de
la sobriété, je pense que pour le pour
le l'air comprimé là par contre, c'est
pas de malin à veille qu'on qu'on
atteigne une voiture avec 1000 km
d'autonovie et 300 chevaux en air
comprimé. Donc du coup l'air comprimé,
la sobriété, elle est on va dire
intrinsèquement dedans.
Ça dépend si vous faites un un un
parinis avec quelques politiques qui
brassent beaucoup d'air, on pourra
peut-être le faire. votre question pour
les du moins votre conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Mais alors, c'est pour nous c'est à la
fois facile et difficile de de donner un
conseil, hein.
C'est c'est facile. C'est difficile
parce que nous on a quand même vécu et
puis peut-être plus quand on était jeune
que maintenant avec
pas beaucoup de transport. Donc c'est
une sur mais je dirais une phrase de ma
conclusion, c'est qu'il va falloir
développer une nouvelle forme d'avarice.
C'estàd qu'en gros, il va falloir
quelque part réapprendre à à bouger pour
vivre et non plus vivre pour bouger.
Laurent Castiged, merci.
Merci.
เฮ [musique]